İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar 29 Ocak 2025 Şarjamba günü saat 19.32 59. ders günümüz dersimize başlıyoruz kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar krono kütüphanesini inceliyorduk arkadaşlar krono kütüphanesinden sonra da
random kütüphanesini göreceğiz orası bizi biraz daha yoracak ondan sonra da artık kısmetse yavaş yavaş concurrency konularına geçeceğiz arkadaşlar şöyle bir hatırlayalım krono kütüphanesinde ne var krono kütüphanesinde bir saatler var klaklar bunlar hazır olarak geliyor ve C++ 20 ile sayıları arttı
ama hangi klaklar vardı hatırlayalım system klak steady klak ve high resolution klak aslında üçüncüsü birinci veya ikincinin kür eş ismiydi arkadaşlar hatırlıyoruz
aradaki fark ne biri bizim gerçek zamanımız ayarlanabilir saat yani steady ingilizcesi steady değil ya da monotonik değil örneğin sistem ayarlarından saati değiştirirseniz etkilenecek
ama diğer taraftan gerçek insanı ilgilendiren tarih zaman işlemleriyle ilgili bir interfejsi vardı
steady klak ise ayarlanamaz her yeni tik bir daha gelmeyecek yeni tik daha çok süre ölçümü için kullanılıyor ve gerçek hayattaki tarih zaman işlemleriyle ilgili kullanılamıyor dedik
arkadaşlar klak ne veriyordu bize klak bize kütüphaneye aslında bir epik veriyor bir başlangıç noktası orjin olarak alınan bir nokta
mesela unix epokı 1-1-1970-00-00 dolayısıyla herhangi bir time point bu epiktan geçen süre olarak temsil ediliyor ona da time point diyoruz
bu epoktan öncesi olabilir ya da sonrası olabilir yani epoka göre pozitif bir değer olabilir negatif bir değer olabilir
fakat burada split sınıflardan biri duration sınıfları çünkü duration'ı diğer iki komponent kullanıyor ama duration bağımsız olarak da kullanılıyor
hatırlayalım duration aslında kendisi bir template nasıl bir template de birinci template parametresi duration'ın temsil edildiği tür
int gibi unsigned long gibi double gibi iki arkadaşlar buna representation deniyordu iki period bu da saniyenin kaçta kaçı ya da kaç katı olduğu bilgisiydi
aslında duration türleri basit birer sarmalayıcı sınıf tipik strong type konusuna inşallah ileri C++ kursuna gelirseniz bekleriz diyormuşum
strong types konusuna çok güzel bir örnek zero cost abstraction ile strong type oluşturuyoruz nasıl bir cümle oldu kelimelerin neredeyse hepsi İngilizce
arkadaşlar en son örnekler yapıyorduk biraz da zaman baskısı olduğu için bazı örnekleri doğrudan daha önce kodladığım örnekler üstünde gidiyorduk
ama şimdi şu steady clock'ın kullanılmasına bir örnek verelim arkadaşlar kullanıldığı tipik yer tek yer olmak zorunda değil süre ölçümü örneğin
bir kod oluşturalım ve bu kodun kaç saniye süre ile çalıştığını ölçen krono kütüphanesini kullanarak bir kod yazalım
mesela beraber yazılmanı falstexpr size t size eşittir bir milyon
arkadaşlar bu vektörün size olarak kullanacağım şimdi bu büyüklükte bir vektör oluşturuyorum vektörün int açılımı
töründen vektörünün
şimdilik
şimdilik namespace direktifimi ve krono kütüphanesi içinde krono nested namespace olduğu için onun içinde bir using direktifi kullandım
tekrar söylüyorum üretimde büyük ihtimalle bunları kullanmazdım vektörün int açılımı töründen vektörünün
konstruktörünü size argüman olarak gönderdim ve şimdi arkadaşlar ne yapalım bunu dolduralım rastgele değerlerle işte birazdan öğrenmeye
yapacağımız random kütüphanesinde rastgele sayı üretim motorlarından MT199 UTC kullanalım
hatta bunun tohum değerini de arkadaşlar yine krono kütüphanesi ile oluşturalım hatırlayın system clock
system clock saat türlerimizden biriydi arkadaşlar bunun statik üye fonksiyonu olan nav'ı çağırıyorum
bana bir ne veriyor arkadaşlar
system clock'ın nav fonksiyonu
system clock
krono ile ilgili kısmını
şurada yazalım
bu idiomatik yapayım nav fonksiyonunu çağırıyorum
bana bir time point veriyor
bunun time since epoch fonksiyonunu çağırıyorum
arkadaşlar bunu da tam sayı olarak kullanmak için
count fonksiyonunu çağırıyorum
ama buradan elde ettiğim değer tamamen clock'a bağlı
yani saniyenin kaçta kaçı olduğu
o yüzden şöyle bir
cast işlemi yapalım
duration cast
ya da
duration cast yapmayalım
count
doğrudan unsigned int
dönüştürelim
nasılsa biz bunu saniye olarak kullanmayacağız
static cast
unsigned int
ifade
şimdi bunu
mt19937'e
mt19937 sınıfının konstruktörüne
argüman olarak gönderelim
böylece program her çalıştırıldığında
farklı bir rastgele sayı zinciri gelecek
evet
buraya kadar derleyelim
bir hata yok
şimdi
algoritm başlık dosyasını
arkadaşlar
include edelim
ve algoritm başlık dosyasındaki
generate algoritmasında
birinci ve ikinci parametre vektörün rengini
vec
vegin
artık bunların hepsini biliyorsunuz kabul ediyorum
vec
and
üçüncü parametreye
generator nesnemi geçiyorum
arkadaşlar
biraz bir şeye dikkat
yine burada
kopyalamadan kaçınacağım
çünkü mt19937
bir hayli
kopyalama maliyeti yüksek
bir
nesne
dolayısıyla
burada
belki daha kolay
ve daha düşük maliyetlisi
planda ifadesini kullanayım
engeyi
referans yoluyla capture edeyim
arkadaşlar
ve
return
enge
ama
bir tane de
distribution nesnesi
alalım
uniform
ink distribution
bunları bugün göreceğiz
bist
arkadaşlar
bu da diyelim ki
sıfırla
bir milyon arasında sayı üretsin
dağıtsın daha doğrusu
ve
enge de
dist'i de
referans yoluyla capture edelim
ve
function objectimizi kullanalım
dist
enge
evet
return
dist'i
initialize ettik
dist
evet
return
dist'i
initialize ettik
dist
enge
hıh
bir dakika
bazen gözüm takılıyor benimde
evet
şöyle yapalım
bu
lambda ifademiz
bu da fonksiyonun
return
is
hıh
bir dakika
bazen gözüm takılıyor benimde
evet
şöyle yapalım
bu
lambda ifademiz
bu da fonksiyonun
return
is
enge
şimdi oldu
tamam
evet
ne yaptık arkadaşlar
bir milyon tane
vektöre
ö'e koydum
onu
sıfır bir milyon arası
rastgele sayılarla
doldurdum
rastgele sayıları üretmek için
ve sıfır bir milyon aralığına
dağıtmak için
random kütüphanesinde
bugün
öğrenmeye başlayacağımız
öğeleri
kullandım
şimdi
bu vektörü
sıralayalım
küçükten büyüğe
algoritm başlık dosyası
zaten
include edilmiş
port
wegbegin
weg
and
takip edebildik mi
evet
şimdi
bu sıralama işleminin
kaç saniye
kaç milisaniye
artık ne istersek
tuttuğunu
sürdüğünü ölçelim
tek yapmam gereken
buraya dikkat
steady clock'ın
yine
now fonksiyonunu çağırıyorum
bu bana bir time point veriyor
auto
tp
start
ölçeceğim
event tamamlandıktan sonra
yine
now fonksiyonunu çağırıyorum
ikinci time point alıyorum
auto
tp
end
iki time point arası
bir
duration
ama
clock'a bağlı
ama bakın
burayı özellikle size
göstermek için
önce
clock'a bağlı olduğunu
göstermek için
bir debug edeceğim
tp end
eksi
tp
start
bu bir duration
bu duration'ı
c++
standardını
destekliyorsa
doğrudan
o stream inserteri olduğu için
yazdırabilirim
ama muhtemelen c++ 20
çalıştığınız şirkette
şu an kullanılmıyordur
iostream
bakın bakın
ama ben
buradaki
saatin
kendi süre
birimini kullanmak zorunda
değilim
bunu sadece göstermek için
yazıyorum
evet
bakın şimdi
bu neymiş
nanosaniye
ne kadar nanosaniyeymiş
7 milyar
73 milyar
306 milyon
olmadı
73 milyon
306 bin
nanosaniyeymiş
ama şimdi
ben bunu
arkadaşlar
c++ 20
kullanmadan
yazmak isteseydim
bu
duration ya
istediğim duration'a
kest edebilirim
değil mi
mesela duration'ın
arkadaşlar
double
açılımı
izleyin
duration'ın
double
açılımı
duration
cast
bu
tür
request
ediyorum
ve
bunun
count
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
takip edebildik mi
edebildik mi
cout
dure
bu
artık
doğrudan
saniye değeri
çünkü
duration'ın
double virgül
ratio'nun
1,1
açılımı
tabi
burada gerçek sayı
türü olduğu için
arkadaşlar
ne yapmamda
doğrudan
gerçek sayı
türüne de
dönüştürebilirim
gerçek sayı
representation'la
yani
onu şöyle de
yazabilirdim
örneğin
duration
cast'i hiç
kullanmadan
duration'ın
double
açılımı
türünden
geçiş
nesne
tp
end
eksi
tp
start
hepsi aynı
anlama geliyor
tamam
bu zaten
benim
ne değerim
double
türünden duration
değerim
representation
double
bunun
count
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
ve double
türden
saniye değerini
elde ediyorum
cout
salaniye
arkadaşlar
yalnız böyle testleri yaparken
derleyicinin yapacağı optimizasyonu da göz önüne alın
derleyici
observable
behavior
bir değişiklik yoksa
yani
o işlemi
hiç yapmayacak şekilde
kod üretebilir
değil mi bakın
0,076
saniye
yani
saniyenin
yüzde
yedisi
miktarı arttıralım
şurada
size değişkenini
kullanmak istemiştim
o yüzden
tanımladım
arkadaşlar
ama
pardon burada değil
şurada
hani kullanmışım zaten
ama
size
5 milyon
yapalım
0.38
saniyede
5 milyon
V'ye sahip
vektörü
tam sayılardan oluşan
sıraladı
arkadaşlar
şimdi kodun şu kısmına
tekrar bakmanızı istiyorum
şu dönüşüm kısmını anlamanız önemli
burada
duration
cast'i kullanmamamın
nedeni
hatırlayın
geçen dersimizi
daha
fine
türden
daha
coarse
türe
doğrudan
arkadaşlar
örtülü dönüşüm
yok idi
ama
coarse
türe
kaba
örtülü dönüşüm
var idi
ama
representation
eğer
gerçek sayı
türü ise
her zaman örtülü dönüşüm var
ama
şimdi mesela bakınız
milisaniye yapmak isteseydim bunu
milisaniye zaten
standart
kütüphanenin
kendi türü
miliseconds
arkadaşlar
santart
hatasının nedenini anladınız mı
çünkü
benim buradan elde ettiğim
duration
miliseconds'dan
daha
arkadaşlar
finer
bir tür
dolayısıyla
burada örneğin
duration cast'i kullanmak
kullanmak zorundayım
duration
cast
miliseconds
evet
duration cast
miliseconds
bir yerde bir yazım hatası var
şöyle parantezler bol bol olunca
duration cast
evet
bazen intelisans ile sapıtıyor
miliseconds
tamam
şimdi
argüman
tpant
eksi
tp
start
tamam
şimdi
bunun
count
fonksiyonunu çağırırsam
bu da
milisaniye değeri
evet bakın
403 milisaniye
yani 403 milisaniye aşağı yukarı saniyenin yarısı demek değil mi
evet
arkadaşlar
son olarak
hazırladığım başka bir örneğin üstünden geçelim
bu sefer kodu yazmayalım
şu
system clock'ı kullanan bir kod daha biraz da c'nin standart kütüphanesini hatırlatmaya yönelik
arkadaşlar
şimdi bakın
11. satırdan başlayarak
time underscore t türünden bir değeri
input parametri olarak alan referans semantiği ile
bir fonksiyonun tanımını görüyorsunuz ya da göreceksiniz
fonksiyonun parametresinin time underscore t ref olduğuna dikkat edin ve const
çünkü
değiştirmeyeceğim bu değişkeni
burada call by value da kullanabilirdik tabi
ama
çoğunlukla bu time underscore t değeri
referans semantiği ile geçiliyor
şimdi bunlar bizim look up table'larımız
artık böyle fonksiyon içinde oluşturulan look up table'ların
neden statik yerel değişken yapıldığını tahsiye kursunda anlatmıştım
ne bu yazılar değişecek
ne de dizinin elemanları değişecek
o yüzden
task pointer to task yaptım
dizinin elemanlarını
böylece indekse
aylara erişebileceğim
arkadaşlar
aynı şekilde günler için de bir look up table'ı oluşturdum
haftanın günleri için
standart local time fonksiyonunu çağırarak
local time'ın geri dönüş değerinden
strak tm nesnesinin adresini elde ettim
efendim
bu
o stream nesnesinin format state'ini değiştirdim
yalnız burada aslında buna gerek yok
kodda değişiklik yapmışım
çünkü c++ 23 standartıyla gelen print fonksiyonu zaten stod formatı kullanıyor
formatta bir şekilde tarihi yazdırıyor
yani aslında şuraya kadar olan kodu bir gösterelim
print time fonksiyonu
örneğin print time
arkadaşlar
time underscore t türünden değer
mesela yedi milyar
iki yüz otuz dört milyon
altı yüz elli bir bin üç yüz kırk beş olsun
pardon yedi milyon
üç yüz kırk altı bin yedi milyon
yedi milyon
on iki milyon
evet
üç yüz
kırk beş
bin
sekiz yetmiş bir olsun
verleyelim
tamamen arkadaşlar rastgele olarak verdim
hiçbir fikrim yok
ne
zamana geldiği hakkında
evet derleyip çalıştırıyoruz
evet
iyi denk gelmiş
yirmi dört mayıs bin dokuz yetmiş
pazar sıfır sıfır yirmi dört otuz bir
biraz arttıralım
on iki milyar yerine on yedi milyar yapalım
on yedi milyon yapalım
şu büyük sayılarla bayağı bir derdim var
evet
yirmi temmuz bin dokuz yetmiş
bu milyar olacaktı herhalde
bir milyar
altı yüz elli iki milyon
üç yüz kırk beş bin sekiz yetmiş bir
evet şimdi
gayet güzel
on iki mayıs iki bin yirmi iki perşembe
on bir elli yedi bir
şimdi gelelim main fonksiyonunda yaptığımız işe
sistem klakın
nav fonksiyonunu çağırarak
geri dönüş değeri olarak
bir time point aldım
yani aslında bu
time point türünden bir nesne
ama time point'in kendisinin de bir
arkadaşlar
jenerik sınıfı olduğunu hatırlayalım
tp nav'ın ne olduğunu görüyorsunuz
sistem klakın time point türü
ya da time point'in
sistem klak açılımı aynı şeydi
şimdi
print time fonksiyonunu yukarıda çağırdım
ama
sistem klakın diğer statik üye fonksiyonunu
to time t
ne yapıyordu
arkadaşlar
time point'i adı üstünde
time underscore t türüne dönüştürüyordu
dolayısıyla
dolayısıyla buradan
system klakın to time underscore t fonksiyonuna yapılan çağrıdan elde edilen
time t değerini yukarıda tanımladığım print time fonksiyonuna argüman olarak gönderdim
yani
buraya kadar olan kod çalıştığımda
aslında bugünün tarihini yazması lazım değil mi
yani çağrıldığı noktadaki time point'i bir yazı olarak vermesi lazım
evet
29 Ocak
çarşamba
19 57
21 mükemmel
şimdi buna dakika ekleyeceğim
kaç dakika input'u standart input'tan alıyorum
arkadaşlar
ve hatırlayınız bakın
time point'ten
eğer duration çıkartırsam
yine time point elde ederim
dolayısıyla
zaten
minutes'te
türeş ismi
dakikanın
bu kadar dakika çıkartarak
bir time point elde ettim
bunu tekrar to time t fonksiyonuna gönderip
geri dönüş değerini
arkadaşlar
timer isimini değişkende tuttum
yine buradaki
timer
time underscore t türünden
yani şöyle de yazsam
olurdu aynı şeyi
ve print time fonksiyonuyla yazdırdım
aynı şeyi
o kadar dakika sonrası için de yaptım
böylece
verilen değerden
verilen dakika değerini kullanacak
şu andaki
tarih zaman time point bilgisinden
o kadar dakika öncesinin
ve o kadar dakika sonrasının
bilgilerini yazdırmış olacağım
hadi bakalım
29 Ocak 2025
şarşamba
on dokuz elli sekiz kırk
arkadaşlar
peki
sekiz bin yedi yüz altmış beş
dakika
öncesi
yirmi üç Ocak
iki bin yirmi beş perşembe
on yedi elli üç kırk
sekiz bin yedi yüz altmış beş
dakika sonrası
dört şubat iki bin yirmi
yirmi beş salı
yirmi iki otuz kırk oluyormuş
biraz arttıralım
kaç dakika
iki yüz otuz dört bin yedi yüz altmış
üç
dakika
öncesi
on dokuz
iki bin yirmi dört
pazartesi
o kadar sonrası
on bir temmuz iki bin yirmi
üç
cuma
az arttıralım
bir milyar
altı yüz elli bir
milyon
beş yüz kırk bir bin iki yüz yirmi üç
yedi
dakika
öncesi
evet herhalde
bir yerde bir hata yaptık
şöyle diyelim
dört
dört yüz elli altı
ya da kırk beş
milyon
yüz yirmi üç bin
dört yüz elli bir bin
yüz otuz dokuz
evet
biraz arttıralım
bir milyon
iki yüz otuz altı bin
yedi yüz on iki
evet
daha iki bin yirmi ikiye ve iki bin yirmi
yediye gitti
arkadaşlar
örnekleri çoğaltmak mümkün
ama
artık bundan fazla detay için
ee
kitaptaki benim oluşturduğum repoya
başvurabilirsiniz
ama ana hatlarıyla gayet güzel
krono kütüphanesini gördüm
burada
özellikle
süre
kürleri
konköransi kütüphanesinde
bazı fonksiyonların
arkadaşlar
parametresi
olacak
mesela
thread başlık dosyasını dahil ediyorum
sadece size göstermek için
arkadaşlar bakın
this thread
arkadaşlar
burada iki tane fonksiyon var
biri
sleep for fonksiyonu
sadece örnek olarak veriyorum
diğeri
sleep until fonksiyonu
şimdi
her ikisi de
aslında
genel bir kalıp oluşturuyor
sleep
thread'i uyutmak için
yani o kadar süre
thread'i
boşta bırakmak için
idle bırakmak için
ama neden iki tane fonksiyon var
biri bizden
duration istiyor
diğeri ise
bizden
time point istiyor
yani örneğin
ben
şu kadar milisaniye
beklemesini istiyorsam
uyumasını istiyorsam
buraya o kadar milisaniye
duration değerini geçeceğim
bunun için sleep for fonksiyonuna çağrı yapacağım
ama elimde bir time point varsa
mesela
diyelim ki
programın çalıştırılmasından
5 dakika
12 saniye
sonraki time point
onu da
sleep until'e
argüman olarak
göndereceğim
o time point
gelinceye kadar
thread'i
uyutmuş olacağız
concurrency konusuna geldiğimizde
bunları göreceğiz
ama sadece
burada değil
kütüphanemizde
concurrency
bazı başka fonksiyonlarda
hep süre
ya da
şu
zaman noktasına
kadar
sorusunun cevabı için
krono kütüphanesindeki
duration
türlerini
ve
time point
türlerini
kullanıyor
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
biraz zor bir konu
başlıyor
rastgele sayı üretimi
kütüphanesi
modern c++'dan önce
c++'ın
hazır
standart
rastgele sayı üretimi
kütüphanesi
yoktu
yani rastgele sayı üretimi
için
üçüncü parti kütüphaneler
kullanılıyordu
arkadaşlar
standart c kütüphanesinden gelen
round ve s round fonksiyonları
c standardının kendisinin de söylediği gibi
sadece çok basit uygulamalarda rastgeleliğin çok az önemli olduğu uygulamalarda kullanılabilir
o yüzden gerçekten rastgele sayı üretiminin önem taşıdığı uygulamalarda aklınızın ucundan bile geçirmeyin
ama şimdi konuya girmek için rastgele sayı üretiminin ne olduğundan başlayalım
yani burada rastgele sayı üretimi ne anlamda kullanılıyor
arkadaşlar
bir slide hazırladım
normalde slide kullanmayı sevmiyorum ama biraz da chat gbt'nin yardımıyla
şimdi önce şuradan başlayalım
bırakalım slide'ı
rastgele sayı üretimi dendiğinde
aslında kast edilen bir sekans şeklinde kullanılabilecek
üniform olarak dağılmış belirli bir aralıkta tam sayılar
bunları doğrudan kullanmak aslında çok da işe yaramıyor
ama bu sayıları nasıl elde ediyorum
arkadaşlar iki ayrı şekilde
birine pseudo random number generation deniyor
buradaki pseudo biliyorsunuz aslı gibi ama aslı olmayan anlamında
o yüzden Türkçe'de sözde terimi kullanılıyor
sözde rastgele sayı üretimi
diğeri de gerçek rastgele sayı üretimi
true random number generation
sözde rastgele üretimi ne demek
aslında burada gerçek anlamda bir rastgelelik yok
matematiksel yöntemlerle algoritmalarla
rastgele olduğu izlenimi veren tam sayıları oluşturuyorum
deterministik bir şekilde
işte bu algoritmalar
seed value denilen bir başlangıç değerini kullanarak
bir sekans şeklinde sürekli bize rastgele sayılar veriyorlar
ve biz bunları rastgele bit kaynağı olarak kullanıyoruz
gerçek rastgele sayı üretimi ise
gerçekten doğadan elde edilen rastgele sayı üretimi
yani hiçbir şekilde önceden kestirilmesi mümkün değil
ikisinin de kullanıldığı alanlar var
şimdi ben özellikle ikisinin de ne olduğunu açıklamaya yönelik
ve nerelerde kullanıldığına yönelik
işte o slide'ı hazırladım biraz hızlı geçelim diye
ama buranın anlaşılması son derece önemli
şimdi burada sözde rastgele sayı üretiminin
deterministik olması ne demek
son derece basit
aynı seed value kullandığınız zaman
aynı sayı sekansını
aynı sayı zincirini elde edeceksiniz
hangi algoritmayı kullanırsanız kullanın
bunun da sağladığı faydalar var
gerçek rastgele sayı üretimi
çoğunlukla external device'lar gerektirdiği için
yavaş ama rastgeleliği ölçen kriterler açısından
ideal çoğunlukla
ama sözde rastgele sayı üretimi
deterministik
diğeri deterministik değil
daha hızlı doğrudan bilgisayarın işlem gücünden faydalanıyorum
bazı algoritmaları implemente etmek için
ama bunlarda rastgeleliğin gerektirdiği
bütün kriterleri mükemmel olarak karşılamıyorlar
birden fazla rastgele sayı üretim algoritması var
endüstride yaygın olarak kullanılan
şimdi şöyle hızlı bir şekilde
üstünden geçmek istiyorum
ben de hayatımda ilk defa chat GPT'yi
chat GPT'yi bu amaçla kullandım
bayağı da başarılı
burada özellikle çok teknik bir dil kullanmadan
basit yani herkesin anlayabileceği şekilde
matematiksel background olmayan kişilerin de anlayabileceği şekilde
bazı sorular sorarak rastgele sayı üretimiyle ilgili
verdiği cevapları yapıştırdım
benim katılmadığım ya da sizin katılmadığınız yer olursa
lütfen chat ekranına yazın
arkadaşlar önce şuradan başlayalım
rastgele sayı üretimi neden önemli
çünkü birçok yerde kullanıyor
ve kullanıldığı yerlerin önemli bir kısmı yazılımla ilgili
yani programlarla ilgili
mesela bizim yazacağımız C++ programları
rastgele sayı üretiminden faydalanacak
mesela bakın ne demiş
bilgisayar oyunları ve grafiklerde
düşmanların hareketleri
rastgele harita oluşturma
eşya düşme oranları gibi
oyun mekaniklerinde
örnek Minecraft
dünyaları rastgele oluşturmak için
sözde rastgele sayı üretimini kullanır
örnek
FIFA oyuncuların rastgele hava koşullarında maç yapmasını sağlar
kumarhaneler
yani İngilizce kasinolar
piyango ve bahis sistemleri
bunların hepsi yine
C++ programlarının kullanıldığı
C++ dilinin kullanıldığı alanlar
online poker
slot makineleri
rulet oyunları
örneklemiş bir çevrim içi
online kumarhane
kartları rastgele dağıtmak için
sözde rastgele sayı üretimini kullanıyor
milli piyango gibi sistemler
kazanan numaraları rastgele belirlemek için
sözde rastgele sayı üretimini kullanıyor
ama bu Türkiye için doğru olmayabilir
çünkü Türkiye'de milli piyango bile
umarım böyle söylediğim için başımda derde girmez
burada bile bizimkiler bir şekilde hile yapmayı başarıyorlar
evet
kumarhaneler
piyango ve bahis sistemleri
şifreleme ve siber güvenlik
şifreleme anahtarları
güvenli parola üretimi
ağ güvenliği gibi kritik alanlar
örneğin WhatsApp
mesajların şifrelenmesi için rastgele anahtarlar üretir demiş
bankaların tek kullanımlı şifreleri
one time password
yine sözde rastgele sayı üretimiyle oluşturuluyor
bilimsel simülasyonlar ve araştırmalar
fizik biyoloji finans ve mühendislikte rastgele veriler üretmek için kullanılır
arkadaşlar mesela ben çok kullanıyorum
neden biliyor musunuz
çünkü benim çalıştığım alan
daha önce de belki söylemiştim algoritmik trading
ve algoritmik trading tarafında da
kodlamadan çok algoritma geliştirme tarafındayım
yani kodlamayı da kendim yapıyorum büyük ölçüde
ama orada bazı algoritmalar mesela genetik algoritmalar
rastgele sayı üretiminden faydalanıyor
ve orada rastgele sayı üreticisinin kalitesi son derece önemli
simülasyonlarda gerçekten yaygın olarak kullanılıyor
iklim değişikliği simülasyonları
demiş örnek hastalık yayılım modelleri
sözde rastgele sayı üretimiyle rastgele hasta hareketlerini simüle ediyor
makine öğrenimi ve yapay zeka
işte gündemde olan en fazla gündemde olan konu
Çinlilerin
Çin'in piyasaya girmesiyle
borsanın ne olması birdenbire düşmesi
veri setlerini rastgele karıştırma
rastgele ağaç algoritmaları
örnekleme işlemleri gibi
arkadaşlar yapay zeka alanlarında kullanılır
derin öğrenme modelleri
rastgele başlangıç ağırlıkları ile eğitilir
örneğin chat GPT gibi modellerin
kendisinden bahsediyor
rastgele cevapları üretmesi için kullanılır
şifre üretme ve güvenlik
kullanıcılar için güçlü rastgele
şifreler oluşturur
bunların hepsini
c++ kodu ile gerçekleştirebiliriz
implemente edebiliriz
yazım testleri
yine benim rastgele sayı üretimini
en fazla kullandığım yer test işlemleri
mesela arkadaşlar
bir database'i oluşturacaksınız
ama milyonlarca kişi olacak
database'de
onların bir takım bilgileri olacak
diyelim ki
isimler
efendim
yaş
kilogram
ağırlıkları
boyları gibi
o verilerin hepsini rastgele oluşturabilirsiniz
otomatik test sistemleri
yazılımı rastgele girdilerle test etmek için
rastgele sayı üretimi kullanır
oyun geliştiricileri
bir karakterin rastgele duvarın içine sıkışıp sıkışmadığını
test etmek için kullanıyormuş
bu bana biraz şüpheli geldi
bir bantacılık yazılımı rastgele senaryolarla
hata testleri yapar
bu mantıklı
müzik ve sanat üretimi
rastgele müzik ve sanat eserleri üretmek için kullanılır
mesela
Serdar Ortaç'ı düşünün
onun bütün parçaları birbirine benziyor
değil mi?
mesela
gerçekten böyle bir şey yapmış bir arkadaş
Serdar Ortaç şarkısı üretiyor
rastgele sayı üretiminde kullanarak
örnek
adama da ayıp oluyor ama
yapay zeka destekli müzik üretim sistemleri
rastgele notalar oluşturarak
benzersiz şarkılar ve siteler
gibi gibi
buradan çıkan
sağlık ve tıp araştırmaları
trafik simülasyonları
arkadaşlar trafik simülasyonları
gerçekten rastgele sayı üretiminin
yoğun olarak kullanıldığı yerler
şimdi gerçek rastgele sayı üretimine biraz değinmek istiyorum
çünkü bu da çok önemli
İngilizce'de True Random Number Generation deniyor
diğerinden farkı
bu doğal fiziksel süreçlerden gelen
tamamen rastgele verileri kullanarak
gerçek hayattan gelen veriyle rastgele sayı üretme işlemi
arkadaşlar bunun en önemli özelliği
deterministik değil
yani belirli bir tohum değeriyle
aynı şekilde elde edilebilecek sayılardan bahsetmiyoruz
artık
fiziksel dünyadan gelen rastgele olaylar
matematiksel algoritmalarla tahmin edilemez olduğu için
gerçek rastgele sayılar oluşturabiliriz
burada biraz böyle çocukça bir cevap vermiş
ama doğru
bilgisayarlar kendi başlarına rastgele olamaz
çünkü gerçek rastgelelik
Cenab-ı Allah'a mahsustur
bunu da ben ekleyeyim
çünkü belirli algoritmalar çalıştırırlar
işte burada bahsettiği deterministik olduğu
bakın burası önemli
bazılarını ben de bilmiyordum
gerçek rastgele sayı üretiminde
2-3 tanesinin farkındaydı
nelerin kullanıldığı
bu en çok kullanılan aslında yöntemlerden biri
elektronik devrelerdeki rastgele
elektriksel dalgalanmalardan faydalanıyor
arkadaşlar
mesela gerçekten Intel ve AMD işlemcilerinde
rastgele sayı üreticisi çipler var
neden rastgelemiş bu fiziksel olarak
elektronların hareketi tamamen tahmin edilemezdir
bu yüzden üretilen sayılar gerçekte rastgeleidir
radyoaktif bozulmadan faydalanıyor
radyoaktif atomların ne zaman bozulacağını tahmin etmek imkansızdır
örnek bir Gaier sayıcı ile radyoaktif bir maddenin yaydığı parçacıklar
rastgele zaman aralıklarında algılanır
ve bu bilgiler kullanılarak rastgele sayılar üretilir
çünkü atomik seviyede gerçekleşen olaylar
tamamen doğa yasalarına bağlıdır ve tahmin edilemezdir
atmosferik gürültü
ingilizce atmospheric noise deniyor
arkadaşlar en çok gerçekten gerçek rastgele sayı üretim cihazlarında
kullanılan yöntemlerden biri en fazla
doğal radyo dalgaları ve yıldırımların yarattığı atmosferik gürültüler kullanılır
örnek random org sitesi
dünyadaki radyo dalgalarının gürültüsünü ölçerek gerçek rastgele sayılar üretir
arkadaşlar bir boş zamanınızda bu random orga girin müthiş bir site
yani gerçek rastgele sayı üretiminden
faydalanmak için kendi kodunuzu oluşturuyorsanız
buradan örnek data alabilirsiniz
neden rastgele?
atmosferdeki radyo sinyalleri
havanın değişimi
güneş fırtınaları ve kozmik olaylardan etkilenir
bu da tamamen rastgele sonuçları oluşturur
kuantum mekaniği
fotodetektörler ve kuantum gürültüsü
kuantum seviyesinde parçacıkların hareketi tamamen rastgelidir
geçiyorum
bu gerçekten yine çok sık kullanılıyor bilgisayar sistemlerinde
kullanıcı davranışlarından hareketle rastgele sayı üretimi yapılıyor
ben buna gerçek rastgele sayı üretimi diyemiyorum
bu da benim uydurduğum terim olsun
semi random true random number generation
çünkü siz bilgisayarı kullananın
fareyi hareket ettirmesi
klavyeye basma süreleri
vesaire gibi inputları alıyorsunuz
bu da tabi insana bağlı olduğu için
bilgisayarı hep aynı şekilde kullanılıyorsa
biraz yarı deterministik olduğu söylenebilir
örneğin linux'ın dev random dosyası
klavye ve fare hareketlerinden gelen rastgele girdileri kullanarak
rastgele sayılar üretir
neden rastgele
işte benim demiz söylediğimin tersini söylüyor
insanların fareyi mouse'u tam olarak nasıl hareket ettireceğini
veya tuşlara tam ne zaman basacağını önceden tahmin etmek çok zordur
doğru ama yine de tahmin edilebilir
tahmin edilebilir
şimdi
burası bence çok önemli
gerçek rastgele sayı üretimiyle
sözler rastgele sayı üretiminin
karşılaştırılması
arkadaşlar gerçek rastgele sayı üretimi fiziksel olaylar
işte gördük elektronik gürültü
radyoaktif bozulma ve bazıları
ama sözler rastgele sayı üretimi
her zaman algoritmik
matematiksel algoritmalar kullanılıyor
sözler rastgele sayı üretimi
deterministik algoritmanın bir tohum değeri var
işte burada başlangıç değeri demiş
İngilizce'de kullanılan terim seed value
aynı seed value için
aynı rastgele sayıları elde ediyorum
oysa gerçek rastgele sayı üretiminde tekrarlama ihtimali yok
dolayısıyla bazı uygulamalarda zaten bundan faydalanıyoruz
yani tekrarlanabilir olması
bütü anlamında değil
yerine göre o zaten gerekli bir özellik
gerçek rastgele sayı üretimi yavaş
çünkü fiziksel süreçlere bağlı
arkadaşlar bir takım cihazlar da kullanmak zorundasınız
ama sözler rastgele sayı üretimi sadece matematiksel hesaplama yapıyor
yalnız
gerçek sözler rastgele sayı üretimi
özellikle kriptografi tarafında yetersiz kalıyor
mesela
standart kütüphane
c++ standardı
açıkça belirtmiş
c++'ın standart random kütüphanesini hemen her yerde kullanabilirsiniz
ama kriptolojide değil
kriptoloji için bazı özel algoritmalar
ya da gerçek rastgele sayı üretimi kullanılıyor
arkadaşlar
şimdi rastgele sayı üretimi ile ilgili algoritmalara bakalım
şu anda ekranda gördüğünüz cppreference.com'dan
arkadaşlar
bizim rastgele sayı üretim kütüphanemizin başlık dosyası random
demin kullanmıştım
yani burada
herhangi bir öğeyi kullanmak için random başlık dosyasını inklude edeceksiniz
şimdi bu kütüphanede ne var
arkadaşlar burada rastgele sayı üretimi ile ilgili
konu ile yeni tanışanların çoğunlukla anlamadığını gördüğüm
sezdiğim önemli bir noktaya değineyim önce
arkadaşlar şimdi rastgele sayı üretim algoritmaları
nihayetinde belirli bir aralıkta rastgele
üniform olarak dağılmış rastgele sayıları bize bit kaynağı olarak veriyor
yani şimdi düşünün biraz kere sayı üretim algoritması size 0 dahil 32 bit max arasında bir değer veriyor
bunu nerelerde kullanabilirsiniz ki hemen
hiçbir yerde
çünkü şöyle bir sayı elde ediyorsunuz örneğin 2 milyar 657 bin 912 443
biz bunun bitlerinden faydalanarak
ne yapıyoruz
elde edilen bu rastgele sayıları
belirli bir dağılım modeliyle
işte burada dağılım terimi
ingilizce distribution
belirli
bir dağılım modeliyle
bir olasılık dağılımıyla
kullanabileceğimiz
tam sayılar ya da gerçek sayıları
dönüştürüyoruz
yani rastgele sayıların
üretilmesi başka
bunların
belirli bir matematiksel
olasılık modeliyle
belirli aralığa dağıtılması
sürekli ya da süreksiz
tamamen başka
o yüzden bizim kütüphanemizde
iki önemli
birbirinden ayrı
ama birbirleriyle ilişki içinde kullanılan
birleşenler var
biri rastgele sayı
üreticileri
diğeri ise
üretilen rastgele sayıları
input olarak alıp
onları
bir olasılık dağılımıyla
belirli aralığa dağıtan
arkadaşlar sınıflar
ikinci gruba
diyorum
birinci gruba da
uniform random bit
generator
yani rastgele bit üreten
sınıflar
işte bunlara da
bunların özellikle
jenerik sınıflardan
elde edilen
gerçek sınıflara da
engine demek yaygın
ama arkadaşlar
bu rastgele sayı üreticisi
sınıflar
hemen hepsi
template
dolayısıyla biz
templitleri doğrudan
kullanmak yerine
o templitlerin
belirli template
argümanlarıyla
açılmış
specialization'larını
kullanıyoruz
şimdi
devam edelim buradan
burayı anlamamız
standart kütüphaneyi anlamamız
için son derece önemli
bakın şimdi
bu cppreference.com
diyor ki
random number
library provides
classes that
generate random
and pseudo
random numbers
gerçek
rastgele sayı üretimi
de var ama
bunun için tabi
sistemin
ya da derleyicinin
bir şekilde destek
vermesi gerekiyor
burada neler var
şunu da açayım
bir zahmet
burada neler var
uniform random bit
jeneratörleri
burada
urbg
kısaltılıyor
bunlar rastgele
sayı üretimi
motorları
arkadaşlar
ağırlıklı
bir de
rastgele sayıları
dağıtan
belirli olasılık
modeliyle sınıflar
mesela bu olasılık
modeli
uniform dağılımı
olabilir
normal dağılımı
biliyorsunuz
diğer ismiyle
Gaussian
Distribution
Poisson
Distribution olabilir
Bernoulli
onlardan da biraz
bahsedeceğim
evet
işte
bu ikisini
kullanarak
rastgele
bit
kaynağı
üretip
bu
enjinlerle
onları
Distribution
sınıf nesnelerine
bunların hepsi
function object
vererek
işimize yarayacak
rastgele
sayıları üretiyoruz
şimdi burada
C++ 26'yla gelen
Philox motorunu saymazsak
onu ben de henüz kullanmadım
arkadaşlar
üç tane temel
algoritma var
biri
Linear Congreational Engine
Linear Congreational
algoritmasını
implemente ediyor
Mersenne Twister Engine
Mersenne Twister
algoritmasını implemente ediyor
Subtract with Carry Engine
Subtract with Carry
ya da
diğer ismiyle
Lacked
Fibonacci
yanlış söylemeyim
şunlardan birinin
diğer ismi
Arkadaşlar
şimdi
bu rastgele
sayı üretimi algoritmalarının
belirli özellikleri var
yani
belirli avantajları
ve
dezavantajları var
Oğuzhan Bey diyor ki
hocam her yeni standart geldiğinde
projenizi upgrade ediyor musunuz
ya da ne kadar sürede
yani
biraz refactoring yapabiliyorum
yeni öğelerle
ama çoğunlukla
değiştirmiyorum
çünkü zaten ben minimal
C++20 kullanıyorum
C++23 desteği de şu anda
zaten çok fazla yok
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
burası işin matematik kısmı
bu algoritmaların
birbirinden
farkı ne
ama bakın
ee
dört tane algoritma
random
başlık dosyasında
dört tane
motor var
rastgele sayı üretim motoru
ve
linear
congressional
algoritmasını
implemente ediyor
birincisi
ikincisi
Mercentwister
algoritmasını
üçüncüsü
işte demin doğru söylemişim
Subtract with Carry
ve
diğer ismiyle
Lacked
Fibonacci algoritmasını
implemente ediyor
bu algoritmalardan
bazıları çok
basit
yani böyle bir
ortaokul lise
seviyesinde
çocuklara
anlatabileceğiniz
basitlikte
ama bazıları
çok karmaşık
mesela Mercentwister
bir hayli karmaşık
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bir de
burası biraz
işi daha karmaşık
kılıyor
burayı çok dikkatli
izleyelim çünkü
okuyarak belki doğrudan
anlamanız mümkün değil
arkadaşlar
şimdi rastgele
sayı üretim motorları
az önce
saydığımız
rastgele
sayı üretiyor
ya
fakat bunları
bazı
başka sınıflar
kullanarak
bunları adaptör
sınıflar diyelim
biraz daha
özenleştirebiliyoruz
mesela
Discard Block Engine
aslında
bir rastgele
sayı üreticisini
alıyor
ama onun ürettiği
sayıların
hepsini vermiyor
bazılarını
kullanmadan
kullanarak
veriyor
yani
aslında
başka bir rastgele
sayı üreticisini
kullanıyor
ama
onun ürettiği
rastgele sayıların
bazılarını
discard ediyor
yani
output olarak
vermiyor
Efendim
shuffle order
engine
bu da
rastgele sayı üreticisini
kullanıyor
bunlar örnek
hepsini bilmemiz
gerekmiyor
rastgele sayı üreticisini
kullanıyor
ama
onun sırasını
değiştiriyor
yani
farklı bir sırayla
veriyor
evet
arkadaşlar
mesela
linear
congruential engine
o kadar basit
bir algoritma ki
burada matematiksel
açılımını
görüyorsunuz
bakın
her yeni tel
hatta şurada göstermiş
bakın
olabilecek en basit
algoritma
linear
congruential engine
üç tane
burada değerimiz var
biri
multiplier
çarpma faktörü
biri arttırma faktörü
increment
diğeri de
mod faktörü
ve bizim
bir deneye ihtiyacımız var
seed value'ya
mesela demiş ki
seed value olarak
7'yi alalım
şu işlemi yapıyor
bakın şuradaki değerlerle
5 çarpı 7
artı 3
buradan elde edilen sayının
16'ya bölümünden
kalanı alıyor
ve ilk rastgele sayı olarak
6'yı veriyor
sonra
bakın burada
6'yı kullandı
ve
aynı
aritmetik işlemlerle
ikinci rastgele sayıyı veriyor
ikinci rastgele sayıyı
kullanarak
aynı matematiksel işlemlerle
üçüncü sayıyı veriyor
arkadaşlar
burada şunu da söylemek gerekiyor
en önemli noktalardan biri
hangi algoritmayı
kullanırsanız
kullanın
algoritmanın sonuçta
bir frekansı olacak
yani
ya da
periyot terimini kullanabilirsiniz
yani
belirli sayıda
rastgele sayı
ürettikten sonra
tekrara girecek
ama
o da
algoritmaya bağlı olarak
ya da seçilen bazı
sabitlere bağlı olarak
o
çok büyük bir değer de olabilir
daha küçük bir değer de olabilir
tabi
tipik olarak istenen
tekrara
geç girmesi
yani
ne kadar uzun bir periyotta
tekrara girerse
o kadar iyi
diğer
başka kriterler de var
tabi
mesela şöyle olsaydı
arkadaşlar
32.767 tane sayıyı üretecek
ama
32.768. sayı
yine ilk sayı olacak
o zaman burada
tekrara girme
frekansı
32.767 olacak
ama birazdan göreceğiz
t19.937'de
o frekans değeri
ben frekans diyorum
doğru terim
belki değil ama
daha iyi anlatıyor
2 üzeri
arkadaşlar
19.937-1
çok çok büyük bir değer
evet
şimdi
şuradan da
açayım ben
cppreference.com'u
bir de oradan göstereyim size
arkadaşlar
burayı iyi bir okumanızda da fayda var
biz çok örnek yapacağız ama
izleyin
burada göstermek istediğim bir yer var
evet
bakın şimdi
burada basit bir kıyaslama yapmış
diyor ki
linear congruential engine
is moderately fast
yani
yeteri kadar hızlı
hızlı sayılır anlamında
ama
çok küçük bir storage istiyor
yani eğer storage ile ilgili bir probleminiz varsa
mesela
linear congruential engine
kullanmayı seçebilirsiniz
değil mi
mercantile engine
arkadaşlar
çok büyük yer kaplıyor
mesela bizim
standart kütüphanedeki
mt19937
türü
o türden bir nesne
5000 byte yer kaplıyor
ne demiş bakın
greater state storage requirements
yani daha büyük bellek alanına ihtiyaç duyuyor
ama
doğru parametreleri kullanırsanız
ki o parametreler bize hazır olarak geliyor
en uzun tekrar etmeyen sekansı
sekansı veriyor
arkadaşlar mersen twister
mersen matematikçi biliyorsunuz
fransız matematikçi
ve mersen prime'ları var
mersen prime'ın ne olduğunu
ben c kursunda bazı konuları anlatırken gösteriyorum
mersen prime'ları ve perfect number'lar arasındaki ilişki
burada neyse daha fazla ilerlemek istemiyorum
sonuçta hepsinin birbirine göre avantajı ve dezavantajı var
kullanmak istediğiniz yerin neresi olduğuna bağlı olarak
bunlardan birini seçebilirsiniz
mesela benim yaptığım işte
bunların arasında yine bana en uygun olan mersen twister
yani benim işimi görüyor
ama bu sizin işinizi de göreceği anlamına gelmiyor
özellikle şuraya dikkat
ne diyor
none of these random number engines are cryptographically secure
yani kriptografik açıdan bunların hiçbiri güvenli değil
eğer bu açıdan güvenlik istiyorsanız
bir kripto kütüphanesi kullanın diyor
mesela open ssl'in rent bytes'i
şimdi izleyin
burası çok önemli
arkadaşlar
normalde bu rastgele sayı üreticileri
template kodlar
fakat bizim kullandığımız konkret sınıflar
bu template'lerin
belirli template argümanlarıyla
açılmış specialization'ları
işte mesela mt19937
bakın kaç tane template parametresi var
mersen twister engine'in
uint fast 32 underscore t
bu üretilecek rastgele sayıların türü
bu rastgele üretilecek sayıların kaç byte olduğu
vesaire gibi değerler var
bu algoritma mersen twister
1998 yılında
32 bitlik versiyonu
Matsumoto ve Nishimura tarafından
keşfedilmiş bulunmuş
bunun 64 bitlik versiyonu
mt19937
buradaki mt19937
o frekansı belirliyor
yani 2 üzeri 19937
eksi 1
arkadaşlar
bu değer
kadar
tekrara girmiyor
işte bundan sonrakiler
tekrar
yine
diğer
oluşturulmuş hazır sınıflar
bazıları adaptörleri kullanıyor
yanında yazmış
mesela
knutun engine'i
aslında
min std round 0
engine'ini kullanıyor
ama onu shuffle order engine'i
adapte ediyor gibi
bir de şöyle bir şey var
ben kullanmayı sevmiyorum ama
derleyici
türeş ismi
type aliası
type def ismi
default random engine olan
bir tür de vermek zorunda
ama
default random engine
bu yukarıdakilerden
hangisinin eş ismi
bu tamamen derleyiciye bağlı
ama benim kullandığım
siz de bakın kontrol edin
derleyicilerin
hepsinde istisnasız
default random engine'i kullandığınız zaman
aslında
mt19937'i kullanmış oluyorsunuz
şimdi buradan devam edelim
biraz daha
konuşalım
biraz da distribution'dan bahsedelim
Arkadaşlar şimdi dağılım son derece önemli
yaptığınız işte
rastgele sayıları
doğrudan kullanmak yerine
bir olasılık dağılımına ihtiyacınız var
şimdi olasılık dağılımı
buradaki
olasılık teorisinde
neye karşılık geliyor?
iki tane önemli
burada nitelik var
biri hangi değerlerin
mümkün olduğu
yani
dağılım sonucu hangi değerler elde edilecek
bir de bunların olasılığı
yani
farklı arkadaşlar değerler için
olasılıkların ne olduğunu belirten
aslında bir dağılımdan bahsediyoruz
şimdi burada iki tane ana gruba ayrılıyor
biri
discrete probability distribution
diğeri ise
aradaki fark şu
discrete
olanda
olasılığı
olasılık dağılımını ölçeceğimiz değerler sayılabilir
mesela diyelim ki
bir, iki, üç, dört, beş, altı
sayılarının
olasılıklarını bulacağız
arkadaşlar
ama
kontinyüs olan da
belirli bir aralık söz konusu
mesela demiş ki
1.23 ile 4.56 arasında
herhangi bir gerçek sayı olabilir
ya da örnek
insanların boyları
tamamen ondalık kısmı da olabilir
neden sürekli dendiğini anladınız
değil mi?
çünkü biz sürekli gerçek sayı aralığından bahsediyoruz
işte burada
en çok kullanılan modeller
tahmin ediyorsunuz
uniform dağılım
normal dağılım
çünkü normal dağılım
doğada en çok karşımıza çıkan dağılım modeli
Bernoulli dağılımı
binomial dağılım
bu a son dağılımı
bunların hepsi standart kütüphanede var
exponential distribution
arkadaşlar gibi
şimdi
evet
şimdi uniform distribution
en sık kullandığımız
uniform distribution ne demek?
o countable değerler
her birinin olasılığı aynı
mesela hilesiz bir zarın
arkadaşlar
atıldığında
bir mi gelecek
iki mi gelecek
üç mü gelecek
dört beş altı mı gelecek
bunların olasılıkları eşit
bir bölü altı
bu tipik bir
bunu modellemek istersek
uniform distribution kullanmamız gerekiyor
uniform distribution da sadece iki tane parametre var
biri işte en küçük değer
o aralıkta
bir de en büyük değer
mesela diyelim ki
1970-2022 arasında
kişilerin doğum yıllarını elde edeceğim
uniform olarak
burada uniform dağılımı kullanabilirim
ama normal dağılım biliyorsunuz bizim çan eğrisi
gauss dağılımı da deniyor
ona da bir bakalım
çünkü bugünkü derste en çok uniform dağılımı ve gauss dağılımını kullanacağız
arkadaşlar
izleyin
evet
normal dağılım
gauss dağılımı da deniyor
çan eğrisi meşhur
arkadaşlar
bir ortalama değeri var
aritmetik ortalama
o simetrik
aritmetik ortalama etrafında yığılma var
ve aritmetik ortalamadan
ortalama diyelim sadece ortalamadan uzaklaştıkça
olasılığı azalıyor
işte buna da Türkçe'de biz ne diyoruz
çan eğrisi diyoruz
burada iki tane önemli parametre var
biri ortalama diğeri standart sapma
ortalamadan standart sapma arttıkça
olasılık değeri azalıyor
birazdan göstereceğim
arkadaşlar
mesela normal dağılımı örnekler
insanların boyları
şimdi bunları neden anlatıyorum
bakın şu hata çok sık yapılıyor
biz diyelim ki programımızda herhangi bir amaçla rastgele sayı üreteceğiz
işte insanların boyları çok iyi örnek
şimdi diyelim ki bizim bir boy aralığımız olsun
1 metre 60 santim ile 2 metre 10 santim arası olsun
diyelim ki aralığımız
ya da 1.50 ile 2.10 arası olsun
biz burada
üniform continuous dağılımı oluştursak
gerçeği yansıtmaz değil mi?
çünkü 1.60, 1.70, 1.80 civarında bir yığılma olması gerekiyor
ama 2 metre 10 santim boyundaki şeyler var mı var
ama bunlar çok çok az
işte bu tamamen normal dağılım
mesela IQ değerleri
insanların IQ ölçümleri normal dağılım
burada 100 civarında bir yığılma var arkadaşlar
ama 100'den uzaklaştıkça olasılığı azalıyor
sınav sonuçları
işte çan eğrisi uygulanıyor ya üniversitelerde
yani ortalama etrafında yığılma var
diyelim ki not ortalaması 60
60 etrafında yığılma var
ama 60'dan daha yüksek notlar
daha düşük olasılıkta
daha düşük notlar yine daha düşük olasılıkta
özellikle bu
gömle sistem programlama tarafında
sizi ilgilendiren kısım
arkadaşlar ölçüm hata değerleri
şimdi siz bir ölçümü
en kere tekrar ediyorsunuz
buradaki hata payları
tipik olarak normal dağılıma uyuyor
burada özellikle bakın finans tarafında
algoritmik trading ile uğraşanlar
orada ben itibar etmesem de teknik analiz dediğimiz bir disiplin var
orada herkes bunu bilir bakın
çünkü bazı teknik indikatörlerde de kullanılır
çok önemli bir kural
ortalamadan
şöyle diyelim
değerlerin %68'i ortalamadan bir standart satma içinde
yani siz ortalamadan bir standart satma uzaklaşırsanız
değerlerin %68'ini yakalıyorsunuz
2 standart satma uzaklaşırsanız %95'i
3 standart satma uzaklaşırsanız %99.7'si
yani değerlerin normal dağılımda %68'i bir standart satma içinde kalıyor
evet bakın burada örnek vermiş çok güzel bir örnek
diyor ki
diyelim ki biz insanların boy ortalamasını
1.75 alalım
bizim için biraz yüksek Türkiye için
ve standart satmayı da 10 cm alalım
o zaman diyor %68'i
burada erkeklerin
165 cm ve 185 cm arasında olacak
1.65 1.85 arasında olacak
%95'i 1.55 1.95 aralığında olacak
%99.7'si 1.45 2.05 arasında olacak
normal dağılım çok sık kullanılıyor
bizim işte de çok sık kullanılıyor
çünkü doğada en çok tekrar eden paten
o kadar çok doğada yer doğal olay var ki normal dağılımı oyan
evet
o yüzden özellikle mesela testlerde normal dağılım uygun insanların kiloları
yaşları arkadaşlar boyları bunlar hep normal dağılım
evet
ha Bernoulli dağılımı
bu da çok sık kullanılıyor programlama tarafında
Bernoulli dağılımı biz de örneklerde kullanacağız
onun için bunları anlatıyorum
arkadaşlar Bernoulli dağılımında bir olasılık var
mesela diyelim ki olasılık 0.25
biz 2 tane olası sonuç var
diyelim ki true false
arkadaşlar
mesela diyelim ki
bilidin yanıyor durumda olma olasılığı 0.25
0.25
sönlük durma olasılığı 0.75
böyle bir dağılımı elde ediyorsunuz
yani iki değerden birine ikisi için de bir olasılık değeri var
bu bire tamamlanıyor bire tümleniyor
mesela arkadaşlar en tipik örnek yazı tura
yazı turada bu p değeri ne
tabi para yine hilesizse onun 0.5 olmasını bekleriz
ya yazı ya tura
evet
yine standart kütüphanede Bernoulli dağılımı için
bizim hazır distribution sınıfımız var
arkadaşlar
evet
mesela discrete distribution
bunun da yine C++'ın standart kütüphanesi ne var
ben çok sık kullanıyorum
arkadaşlar gerçekten bu sınıfın ismi de C++ da discrete distribution
ne olduğunu anlamanız çok önemli
mesela
izleyin
arkadaşlar bir örnek
sizin belirli değerleriniz var
mesela diyelim ki Ocak
Şubat
Mart
Nisan böyle gidiyor aralık
12 tane değer olsun
siz diyorsunuz ki
bunların her birinin olasılığını
ben saplayacağım
mesela diyelim ki
%20'si
Ocak olsun
%5'i Şubat olsun
%6'si Mart olsun
böyle bir
değer seçiyorsunuz
bu sayılabilir değerlerin olasılığı için
ve dağılım bunu uyguluyor
bunu uyguluyor
zaten biz şimdi yazacağımız kodlarda
bunların hepsinin kodunu yazacağız ya
yazacağımız kodlarda
bunu da ölçeceğiz
gerçekten o dağılım modeline uyuyor mu
ne derece başarılı
bunu da ölçeceğiz
şimdi artık yavaş yavaş
C++'ın standart kütüphanesini
öğrenmeye başlayacağız
arkadaşlar
burada önemli bir nokta daha var
yine genelde programcılar
önemini pek idrak etmemiş oluyorlar
anlatacağım
Arkadaşlar
şimdi bu rastgele sayı üreticilerinin
aslında sağladığı
çok önemli bir özellik daha var
o da ne biliyor musunuz
hangi derleyici olursa olsun
diyelim ki
Mersenne Twister Engine kullanıyorsunuz
Efendim Russell
GCC derleyicisini kullanıyor olsun
ben Microsoft'u kullanıyor olayım
Ozan Arm derleyicisini kullanıyor olsun
C++ için
aynı tohum değerinden başlayarak
üretilen sayı sekansı hep aynı olmak zorunda
yani bu garantiyi veriyor
zaten bakarsanız
bir örnek vereceğim
bakarsanız
mesela buradan
Mersenne Twister'ı açalım
bir şey göstereceğim
diyor ki örneğin
şurada bir
verdiği tam sayı test değeri olması lazım
Wikipedia'dan da bakabilirsiniz
şimdi bulurum
mesela diyor ki
üretilen on bininci sayı
şu tohum
default tohum değeri için
üretilen on bininci sayı
bu olmalı
sizde de o olacak
bende de o olacak
hangi derleyiciyi kullanırsanız
kullanın
bu standart gelen rastgele sayı üreticilerinin
belirli tohum değerleri için
oluşturacağı zincir
aynı
yani derleyiciler arasında
bir fark olmamak zorunda
çünkü
aynı algoritmayı
aynı sabitlerle
implemente ediyorlar
birazdan gösteririm onu
arkadaşlar
işte
mt19937
resul cevabı vereceğim size
bulalım onu şimdi
mt19937
Mersenne Twister Engine
ve
onu açalım
şurada aşağıda
evet bakın şimdi
mt19937
aslında Mersenne Twister'ın
daha önce de söylemiştim
şu
argümanlarla
template argümanlarıyla açılımı
yani
her derleyicide
her tohum
aynı tohum değeri için
aynı sayı sekansının oluşması
garanti altında
şimdi bu rastgele sayı üreticileri
bir örnek verelim
arkadaşlar bu rastgele sayı üretim sınıflarının
şu özellikleri var
random başlık dosyasını dahil ediyorum
bundan sonrası tamamen C++'la ilgili olduğu için
burayı iyi dinlememiz gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
öncelikle bizim
bir rastgele sayı üretim motoruna ihtiyacımız var
işte az önce gösterdiğim motorlardan
herhangi birini seçtiğimizi düşünün
ben çoğunlukla
mt19937'i kullanacağım
ama
bu nokta
şunu görürsünüz
bu aslında
bakın
default random engine
derleyiciye bağlı olarak
rastgele sayı motorlarından birinin
eş ismi
mesela benim derleyicimde
ben
default random engine'i kullandığım zaman
mt19937'i kullanmış oluyorum
şimdi
mt19937 için
önce biraz konuşalım
arkadaşlar
bunu kullanırken
bir kere dikkatli olmanız gereken
birinci nokta
bunun
çok yüksek bir storage istiyor olması
5000 byte
isterseniz
bunu gerçekten göstereyim ben size
bakın
iostream
kodlarla oynamak çok eğlenceli aynı zamanda
cout
size of
mt19937
dolayısıyla
kopyalamadan
mümkün olduğu kadar
kaçınmanız gerekiyor
mesela
bir fonksiyona
call by value
olarak geçmek
hele hele
döngüsel bir yapıda
tam bir felaket olurdu
verim efficiency açısından
arkadaşlar
herhangi bir rastgele sayı üretim motorunun
hangi template'in hangi açılımı olduğunu
doğrudan
eğer
derleyiciniz böyle
enkriptik bir string vermiyorsa
bakın
type id
mt19937
name fonksiyonunu çağırıyorum
benim derleyicim olduğu gibi
türü
gerçek türü ismiyle
özdeşleştiren bir string
döndürüyor
name fonksiyonu
c hatta
önce de örnekler yapmıştık
ama gcc de böyle değil
bakın şimdi
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz değil mi
az önce
cppreference.com'dan
gördüğümüz
argümanların aynısı
birinci template parametresi
unsigned int
ikinci template parametresi
üçüncü
tabi bazı parametreler
hatta parametrelerin hemen hepsi
non type parametre
Necat şöyle bir şey kullanma ihtimalimiz var mı
mesela
mersen twister engine'in
bu
sabitlerle oluşturulan
specialization'ı
değil de
başka bir specialization'ı
arkadaşlar orası matematikçilerin işi
şu sabitleri değiştirip
kendiniz ayrı engine'ler oluşturmaya çalışmayın
yani bunlar
çok kullanılan
test edilmiş
en iyi seçilmiş değerleri olarak görülmeli
şimdi
rastgele sayı üreticilerinin ortak özelliği
bunların function object olması
yani
fonksiyon çağrı operatörünün operandı olduğunda
bir fonksiyon çağrılıyor
işte o fonksiyon rastgele sayıyı veriyor
lütfen şimdi dikkat
mt
19.9.37
arkadaşlar izleyin
enge
bir kere bir tohum değeri olması gerekiyor
tohum değeri olarak
default tohum değerini kullanabilirsiniz
seed value
ya da
arkadaşlar
kendi seçtiğiniz tohum değerini
verebilirsiniz
her seed value için
ayrı bir sayı sekansı var
o önceden belli
ben bunu anlatırken
hep şu soruyla karşılaşıyorum
diyor ki madem önceden belli
nasıl rastgele oluyor
bunu bir
şaka olarak kabul etmek gerekiyor
zaten deterministic random
bu demek
mesela
sınıfın
seed
elemanı
izleyin
arkadaşlar
bu fonksiyon
gördüğünüz gibi
seed'i değiştiriyor
yani
eğer siz burada
default
argümanı kullanırsanız
işte
zaten
default'u
sabitiymiş
arkadaşlar
yani
siz default
konstrakt ederseniz
o demin söylediğim
kaçtı
M9
o değeri kullanacak
ama
bunu
konstraktör
argüman olarak da
geçebilirsiniz
mesela diyelim ki
tohum değerinin
şimdi
Resulü sizin sorunuzun da
cevabı geliyor
tohum değerinin
şu sayı olmasını
istediğinizi düşünelim
şimdi
ben
bu tohum değeriyle
10 tane
rastgele sayı üretsem
sonra
aynı programı tekrar
çalıştırırsam
yine aynı sayılar
elde edilecek
izleyin
mesela
10 kez dönen
bir döngü
ENG'yi
ben
fonksiyon çağrı
operatörünün
operandı yaptım
ve
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değeri
benim
elde ettiğim
rastgele sayı
ama bu
32 bit
unsigned
int
aralığında
bir sayı
işte
bu rastgele bit kaynağı
olarak kullanılacak
bunu doğrudan
kullanmam
çok küçük ihtimal
yani ne yapayım
bu aralıktaki sayıları
ama görüyorsunuz
birbirinden çok farklı
sayılar
ama
şöyle bir görsel olarak
kopyalamayayım
bakın
ya da
kopyalayayım
arkadaşlar bakın şimdi
programı tekrar çalıştıracağım
tabii ki aynı sayılar
elde edilecek
mesela
ben şöyle bir şey yapsam
burayı çok dikkatli izleyin
bakın bakın
ne yapacağım
tane sayı üreteceğim
rastgele sayı üreticisiyle
inti eşittir 0
i küçük
10.000
eksi 1
ve
ENG'yi
rastgele sayı üretiyorum
ve
bundan sonraki
sayıyı yazdırıyorum
default değer için
bunlar test değeri olarak
bunu göstermek için
hep kullanılıyor
dokümanlarda
şimdi bakın
see out
ENG
10.000
yani 10.000
rastgele sayının
default tohum değeri için
hangi sayı olduğu
bütün motorlarda
arkadaşlar
belli
bakın bunu birazdan
siz de hatta
ben vakit kaybetmeyeyim
cppreference.com'dan
hemen
ilgili yeri
bulabilirsiniz
şu test değerini
görebilirsiniz
10.000
sayı
bunun
64 bitlik
versiyonu
arkadaşlar
MT
19.000
37.000
burada da
tek farkı ne
64 bitlik sayıları
üretecek
ama
yine
aynı tohum değeriyle
aynı sayıları
elde edeceğim
işte şimdi
bu
rastgele sayı
üretim algoritmaları
belirli aralıkta
tipik olarak
sıfırla n
arasında
üniform
bize rastgele sayı
veriyorlar
işte mesela
MT
19.9.37
hatta
onları da yazdıralım
ben sınıfların
üye fonksiyonlarına
da yavaş yavaş
gireyim
arkadaşlar
MT
19.9.37
ENG
sınıfın
min ve
max
fonksiyonları
ENG
nokta
arkadaşlar
min
evet
bakın
statik üye fonksiyon
hatta
auto
msxpr
compile time'da görebilirsiniz
otop
min
eşittir
ENG'nin
mini
max
ENG'nin
max'ı
bunu
bütün askere sayı üretim
nesneleri
motorları için
bu min ve max değerlerini görebilirsiniz
bakın en küçük
sıfır
en büyük
4 milyar 294 milyon
967 bin
bu ne aslında
32 bit
en büyük işaretsiz
tam sayı
eğer bu
64 bitlik
versiyonu olsaydı
sıfır
efendim
arkadaşlar
8 byte işaretsi oldu
kentilyon küsür olacaktı
bakın
gerçekten
18 kentilyon
küsür
demek ki
bütün askere sayı üretim motorlarının
yani bu sınıfların
min ve max fonksiyonları var
min fonksiyonu
en küçük değeri
max fonksiyonu
en büyük değeri veriyor
fonksiyon çağrı operatörünün operandı yaptığınızda
işte rastgele sayıyı üretiyor
ama biz bunu doğrudan kullanmak yerine birazdan göreceğiz
dağılım sınıflarından birini ya da birden fazlasını seçerek
istediğimiz dağılıma göre bir rastgele sayı elde edeceğiz
ama şimdi rastgele sayı üreticisi sınıfların
önemli birkaç tane özelliği var
biri
bu
ya da daha sonra
tohum değerini arkadaşlar değiştirmek istiyorsam
yani nesneyi oluşturduktan sonra tohum değerini değiştirmek istiyorsam
sınıfın seed fonksiyonunu çağırabiliyorum
bir de
default seed değeri var arkadaşlar
izleyin
bu
default kullanılan seed değerinin
yani siz bir seed value vermezseniz
constructora
default değer olarak
5489'u kullanıyor
mesela
mt199
ve 32
sınıfların önemli bir başka özelliği
buraya dikkat
serialize edebiliyorsunuz
Yani bir engine'in bir state'i var. Burası çok çok önemli. Arkadaşlar bütün rastgele sayı motorlarının motor nesnelerinin örneğin MT19937 bir T zamanında bir state'i var.
O state çok önemli. Çünkü o state'in ne olduğuna bağlı olarak bir sonraki rastgele sayı üretiyor. İşte diyelim ki emirhan garanti veriyor tabii. Diyelim ki ben bir network üstünden benim rastgele sayı üreticimin bir kopyasını vereceğim ve o da o noktadan itibaren aynı sekansı devam ettirecek.
Arkadaşlar nesneyi nasıl göndereyim başka bir yere?
Bu tür işlemlere neden deyini biliyorsunuz. Serializasyon ve deserializasyon.
Serializasyon burada şu anlamda. State'i bir şekilde bir yazıya dönüştürüyor ve o yazıyı arkadaşlar artık siz başka bir yere taşıyabiliyorsunuz.
Ve diğer tarafta o yazıdan hareketle yine ne yapabiliyor arkadaşlar?
Aynı başka bir MT19937 nesnesini aynı state'e çekebiliyor.
Hatta ben size bunu göstereyim bakın.
Bu state bilgisi aslında bir o streame verilebiliyor ve iStream'den alınabiliyor.
Mesela diyelim ki benim şu andaki state bilgimi standart output'a yazdırmak istesem doğrudan yazdırabilirim.
Burada bir şey yanlış anlaşılmasın. Bu değerler benim için bir şey ifade etmiyor.
Önemli olan bunu input olarak kullanıp aynı state'e geri döndürebilmem arkadaşlar.
Arkadaşlar yine aynı şekilde rastgele mesela şöyle bir izleyin.
Bu bence en önemli noktalardan biri.
Mesela bakınız diyelim ki ben 100 tane rastgele sayı ürettim.
1000 tane rastgele sayı ürettim.
Şuradaki state'e bakınız.
Ve ondan sonraki rastgele sayıları yazdırıyorum.
İlk 10 sayı yazdırayım.
Bu örneği çok dikkatli takip edin kafanız karışmazsa.
seeout.
Enge.
Şimdi bunun şu andaki state'ini yani 1000 tane sayı ürettikten sonraki state'ini bir stream nesnesine yazayım.
Serialize edeyim.
StringStream.
SS arkadaşlar.
SS.
ENG.
Şimdi bakın.
MT19937.
ENG2.
Aynı nesneyi de kullanabilirdim.
SS.
ENG2.
Şimdi ENG1 ve ENG2'nin state'leri aynı.
Yani ikisine de rastgele sayı ürettirsem ikisi de aynı rastgele sayıyı üretecek.
Onu da gerçekten gösterebilmek için aynı döngüyü burada oluşturayım.
oluşturayım ve ENG2'yi kullanayım.
Şuraya da şurada da get card çağrısını yapayım.
Bakın şimdi tekrar görüyorsunuz değil mi?
İkisini aynı state'e getirdiğim için ikisi de aynı rastgele sayıları üretti.
Yani bu serialize edilebilmesi de bu sınıfların en önemli özelliklerinden biri.
Önemli bir başka özelliği daha var.
Para vereceğim birazdan.
O da şu arkadaşlar.
Belirli sayıda üretilecek rastgele sayıyı kullanmadan discard edebiliyorsunuz.
Mesela diyelim ki ben şöyle bir şey yapmak istiyorum arkadaşlar.
Demin ki koda bakın şimdi.
Aynısını oluşturacağım.
İlk 9.999 rastgele sayıyı discard edeyim.
ENG.discard.
9.999.
Neden 9.999 tane discard ettim?
Çünkü 10.000. değer test değeri.
Demin size gösterdim.
Aynı değer olduğunu göreceksiniz.
Siyahı arkadaşlar.
ENG.
Takip etmeye çalışın.
Bakın.
Zaten şuraya da yazmışım.
Görüyorsunuz değil mi?
Aynı değer olduğunu.
Aynı test değeri olduğunu.
Niscard işleminin şöyle bir özelliği var.
Ben 9.999 tane sayıyı fiilen üretseydim.
Onun bir işlem maliyeti olacaktı değil mi?
Ama discard benim ilk yaptığım gibi döngüsel bir yapı içinde 9.999 tane o sayıyı üretme işlemini yapmıyor.
Doğrudan o state'e çekiyor.
Yani maliyeti çok daha düşük.
O zaman bir ara verelim.
Saat 21.05 diyelim.
21.25'de devam edeceğiz.
Arkadaşlar mesela bir test yapalım.
Bu bütün derleyicilerde aynı sekansın üretildiğini göstermek için.
Belirli bir tohum değeri alalım.
Tamamen uyduruyorum.
6.541.345
Ve 100.000'inci sayıyı yazdıralım.
Evet bakın 100.000'inci sayı bu.
Bunu buraya kopyalayalım.
Şimdi BCC derleyicisi.
Aynı kodu buraya yapıştırıyorum.
Çalıştırıyorum.
Gördünüz değil mi?
Aynı sayı.
1, 2, 1, 3, 5, 5 diye gidiyor.
Görüyorsunuz tamamen aynı sayı.
İsterseniz siz de kendi derleyicinizle deneyin.
Şimdi o zaman rastgele sayı üretim motoru olan nesnelerin ortak özelliklerini söyledik.
Son kez bir tekrar edelim.
Bir niteliğinden daha bahsedeceğim.
Belirli bir state'e sahipler.
O state'in ne olduğuna bağlı olarak bir sonraki rastgele sayı üretiyorlar.
O state'i bir streame yazabiliyorum ve bir streame yazabiliyorum ve bir streame'den okuyabiliyorum.
Böylece sererizasyon ve desererizasyon yapmış oluyorum.
Bunlar function object.
Funksiyon çağrı operatör fonksiyonu çağrıldığında rastgele sayı veriyor.
Min ve max değerleri arasında rastgele uniform dağılmış bir tam sayı veriyor.
Ve bu sayıları belki çok nadiren doğrudan kullanabiliriz.
Ama çoğunlukla distribution nesneleriyle kullanıyoruz.
Aynı state'teki farklı MT19-937 nesneleri arkadaşlar rastgele sayı ürettiklerinde aynı değeri üretiyor olacaklar.
Tabii tohum değeri aynı olması gerekiyor.
İşte bakınız bunu iki rastgele sayı üreticisinin aynı state'te olup olmadığını karşılaştırma eşit-eşit, eşit değil fonksiyonlarıyla da test edebilirsiniz.
Mesela bakınız arkadaşlar ben deminki kodu buraya yazayım.
Ama 99-1999. sayı ürettikten sonra state'ini yine bir string stream nesnesinde tutayım.
String stream nesnesinde.
String stream.
SS.
ENG.
Ve şimdi MT19-937 ENG underscore 2 SS.
ENG underscore 2.
Şimdi hem sayıyı üretelim hem de arkadaşlar eşit-eşit operatörün operandı yapalım.
IF ENG1 ENG eşit-eşit ENG2 ise Evet Aynı durumda.
AS Hayır Farklı durumda.
Karşılaştırma operatör fonksiyonlarının da görüyorsunuz aynı state için eşit-eşit operatörü true değer döndürüyor.
Operatör fonksiyonu eşit değil de false değer döndürüyor.
Hemen bütün özelliklerinde konuştuk.
Arkadaşlar şimdi tek tek rastgele sayı üreticisi nesneleri göstermeme gerek yok.
Sınıfları göstermeme gerek yok.
Önemli olan buradaki interfeisi.
Yani şimdi mesela siz MT19-937 yerine bambaşka bir engine kullansınız.
Mesela RANLUX48 izleyin.
RANLUX48
Şimdi bütün az önce saydığım interfeis bunda da var.
Bunun da min max fonksiyonu var.
Bunun da default seed'i var.
Efendim discard fonksiyonu var.
Arada bir fark.
Sadece kullandıkları algoritma farklı.
Necati bunda da yine
Aynı seed value için aynı sekans elde edilecek değil mi?
Evet.
Derleyici farklı olsa bile aynı tohum değerinin sekansı aynı olacak mı?
Cevap.
Evet.
Bu bütün engine'ler için deçerli.
Şimdi gelelim asıl bunların kullanımına.
Bunları kullanabilmek için çoğunlukla
arkadaşlar
dağılım nesnesine ihtiyacımız var.
Yani bir rastgele sayı üreticisinin
ürettiği rastgele sayıları
bit kaynağı olarak kullanıp
bunları istenen olasılık dağılımı modeliyle
dağıtan sınıf nesnelerine ihtiyacımız var.
İşte standart kütüphane
arkadaşlar çok sayıda dağılım sınıfı veriyor bize.
Yani matematiksel olarak hangi dağılımı
istediğimize bağlı olarak
işte bakın şimdi onların hepsini bir görelim.
Görüyor musunuz?
Uniform ink distribution, uniform real distribution
bunlar uniform dağıtan
biri arkadaşlar continuous olan gerçek sayılar için
diğeri countable tam sayılar için.
Bernoulli dağılımları
dört tane Bernoulli dağılımı var.
Poisson dağılımları
beş tane Poisson dağılımı var.
Normal dağılım arkadaşlar
bir, iki, üç, dört, beş, altı tane.
Samling distribution, üç tane.
Bunların ne olduğu artık matematiğin konusu
ya da istatistiğin konusu özellikle.
Ama ben şimdi bu dağılım sınıfları
distribution sınıfları nasıl kullanılıyor
onu göstereyim.
Önce uniform ink distribution'dan başlayalım.
En fazla kullanmaya aday olduğunuz sınıf bu.
Yine örneklerde
MT19937'yi kullanayım
ya da default random engine'i kullanabilirim.
Ama burada bir not daha.
Geçen dersimizin konusuydu.
Şimdi burayı çok dikkatli izlememiz gerekiyor.
Arkadaşlar
seed'i iki farklı şekilde verebiliyoruz.
Birincisi
izleyin
tek bir seed olarak
fakat
bir konstruktör daha var.
Bu konstruktör
sizden
bir initializer list istiyor.
O initializer listteki
seed değerlerini
kullanarak
arkada matematiksel bir prosesle
seed elde ediyor.
Yani o konstruktör için
birden fazla
iki olabilir, üç olabilir, beş olabilir
argüman geçiyorsunuz.
Ama
bunun özel bir türü var.
Yani
şimdi
göstereceğim size.
Bu da eleştirilen bir nokta.
Matematiksel olarak
doğru olmadığı
bir şekilde
işte bakın bu
seed
sequence türünden
sizden bir sekans istiyor.
ama
çok da eleştiri var.
Okuyabilirsiniz internette.
Hiçbir işe yaramadığını
ilave bir
ne diyelim
özellik katmadığını
söyleyenler var.
O yüzden ben kullanmıyorum.
Ama şimdi
özellikle bir problemin
ideomatik çözümüne
bakalım.
Mülakatlarda falan da
bunu sorma ihtimalleri yüksek.
Zaten bir önceki
terste göstermiştim.
Bir önceki konuda.
Şimdi bu
aynı seed değeri için
aynı sekansı üretecek.
Fakat bazı programlarda
program her çalıştırıldığında
her programda değil tabii
bazı programlarda
program her çalıştırıldığında
farklı bir sayı zinciri
oluşsun istiyorsunuz.
Mesela Resul Bey
bunu sormuştu.
Bizim kar sınıfında
nasıl oluyor da
hep aynı sayılar gelmiyor.
Bunu yapmanın
iki tane yolu var.
En az
hatta en az
üç tane yolu var.
Birincisi
zamana bağlı bir değer
almak.
Bakınız
10 kez dönen bir döngüde
MT19937
nesnemi
tanımlayayım.
Ve
daha önceden
yaptığımız gibi
krono
başlık dosyasını
inkludet edelim.
Krono namespace için
direktifimizi
kullanalım.
Kolay yazmak için
burada ve
daha önce
yaptığımız gibi
örneğin
system clock'ın
now fonksiyonu
times
since
epoch
beyond
burada bakın
türü uyuşmazlığı
olmasın diye
static cast
ascent
kullanıyor ama
aslında
bunu da
generic kodu
uygulamak
isterseniz
result type
isimli bir
nest type
var.
Yani
MT19937
nin
result type
ama
tabi
ascent
kullansanız
herhangi bir
şekilde
bir problem
yok.
Evet
dünyanın en uzun
ideomatik
deyimi.
İkinci yol ise
buraya dikkat
standart
bir tüphane
bize
bir tane
gerçek rastgele sayı
üreticisi
veriyor ama
bu derleyiciye
bağlı
gerçek rastgele sayı
üretmediğini
kontrol edebiliyorsunuz.
Ama önce bunu bir
kullanalım.
mesela
beş tane
rastgele sayı
yazdırım.
İlk beş sayıyı
tekrar çalıştırıyorum
bambaşka değerler.
Tekrar çalıştırıyorum
ikincisi ise
gerçek rastgele
sayı
üreticisini
kullanmak.
Bu ideomatik
yapıya da
dikkat şimdi
burası
yine
önemli.
Arkadaşlar
random device
isimli
bir
sınıf
var.
Bakın
stud
random
device
bu
random
device
sınıfı
türünden
bir
nesnenin
fonksiyon
çağrı
operatör
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınızda
size yine
rastgele
sayı
veriyor.
Ama
burada
verilen
rastgele
sayı
gerçek
rastgele
sayı.
Yani
örneğin
10 kez
dönen
bir
döngüde
random
device'ın
ürettiği
rastgele
sayıyı
ekrana
yazarsam
yine
program
her
çalıştırıldığında
farklı
sayılar
verecek.
Eğer
gerçek
rastgele
sayı
üreticisi ise
bakın
herhangi bir
tohum
değeri falan
vermiyorum
buna.
Görüyorsunuz
değil mi?
farklı
sayılar.
Bunu test
etmek için
arkadaşlar
elektronların
hareketiyle
mı veriyor?
O derleyiciye
bağlı
rastgele.
O kesinlikle
bir
standartın
koyduğu
koşuluyor.
İzleyin
sınıfın
entropi
isimli
fonksiyonu
var.
Arkadaşlar
işte bu
entropi
öngörülemez
diyeyim
bir yerde
ölçüsü.
RD'nin
entropi
fonksiyonu
double
değer
döndürüyor.
Eğer
sıfır
döndürürse
bu
gerçek
rastgele
sayı
üreticisi
değil.
Mesela
benim
entropi
fonksiyonumun
geri dönüş
değerine
bakalım.
Entropi
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
32'ydi
yanlış
hatırlamıyorsam.
Bakın
yani
ben bunu
gerçek
rastgele
sayı
üreticisi
olarak
kullanabilirim.
O
zaman
şöyle bir
idiom
devreye
giriyor.
Çok
sık
kullanılan
bir
idiom
bakın.
Nesneyi
oluşturuyorsunuz
Constructor'ına
random
device'ın
ürettiği
rastgele
sayıyı
argüman
olarak
geçiyorsunuz.
Bunun
içinde
sadece
bir
kere
kullandığımız
için
o
genel
zaten
iyi
kodlama
ilkesi
isimlendirilmemiş
nesne
yani
geçiş
nesne
kullanmanız
en iyisi.
Şöyle yazıyoruz
random device
türünden
geçiş
bir nesne
oluşturdum.
Onun
fonksiyon çağrı
operatör fonksiyonunu
çağırdım.
Bunun
geri dönüş
değerinde
MT19937'nin
ya da
herhangi bir
engine'in
diğer türlerden
de olabilir
Constructor'ına
argüman
olarak
gönderiyorum.
Yine
şimdi
mürekten
rastgele
sayılara
bakalım.
Bugün
başlangıç
değerleri
şimdi
tamamen
farklı
sayılar.
Gördük
değil mi?
Tamam.
Böylece
zamana
bağlı
bir değer
seçerek
ya da
gerçek bir
üretilmiş
rastgele
sayıyı
seed value
olarak
alıp
programın
her çalıştırıldığında
egzeyar
çalıştırdığımızda
ayrı bir
sayı
zinciri
elde edilmesini
sağlayabilirsiniz.
Özellikle
oyun programlarında
bu çok
gerekiyor
değil mi?
Düşünsenize
mesela
tavla oyunu
eğer siz
tamamen
aynı
sekansla
her defasında
başlatırsanız
oyunculara
hep aynı
zarlar
gelir.
Öyle
değil mi?
Evet.
Şimdi
gelelim
dağılım
sınıflarına
distribution
sınıflarına.
Arkadaşlar
az önce
söylediğim gibi
bizim
engine'lerimiz
sadece
rastgele
bit kaynağı
yaratıyor.
Şimdi o
matematiksel
modele
olasılık
dağılımına
göre
belirli
aralıkta
rastgele
sayıları
verecek olan
bizim
distribution
sınıflar.
Onlar
nasıl
kullanılıyor?
Çok
dikkatli
izleyin.
Ayrıntılı
göreceğiz ama
diyelim ki
dist
ben genellikle
bu ismi
kullanıyorum.
Herhangi bir
distribution
sınıfı
türünden
nesne
uniform
distribution
sınıfı
türünden
olabilir
efendim
bütün
uniform
distribution
sınıfı
türünden
olabilir
uniform
real
distribution
sınıfı
türünden
olabilir
poason
distribution
sınıfı
türünden
olabilir
ama
hepsinin
fonksiyon
çağrı
operatör
fonksiyonu
var.
Yani
bir başka
deyişle
distribution
sınıfları
da
function
object
sınıfları
fakat
bunların
fonksiyon
çağrı
operatör
fonksiyonları
rastgele
sayı
üreticisini
istiyor.
Yine
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
işte
bizim
kullanacağımız
rastgele
sayı.
Hadi
bir örnek
verelim
şimdi.
Bakınız
MT19937'yi
kullanıyorum.
Zamana
bağlı değil
random device
kullanacağım.
Ki
zorunlu
değil
tabii ki.
Ve
şimdi
Uniform
Int Distribution
sınıfı
türünden
bir
nesne.
Bu bir
sınıf
şablonu.
Uniform
Int Distribution'daki
template
type
parametresi
arkadaşlar
yine
bizden
üretilecek
rastgele
sayının
türünü
istiyor.
Default
template
argümanı
int.
Yani
böyle
yazarak
neyi
sağlamış
oluyoruz?
Template
argümanı
olarak
inti
vermiş
oluyoruz.
Ama
örneğin siz
long
türden
sayı
üretmek
istiyorsanız
template
argümanını
long
yapacaksınız.
Eğer
örneğin
arkadaşlar
long
yapmak
için
template
argümanını
long
yapacaksınız.
Eğer
default
construct
ederseniz
sıfır
ve
max
değerlerini
kullanıyor.
Yine
C++
arkadaşlar
standardıyla
bu
ne
gelmişti
hatırlıyorsunuz
sınıf
şablonları
için
template
argümanının
deduction
yapılması
dedios edilmesi
özelliği
gelmişti
stat
deniyordu.
Stat
den
da
faydalanabiliyorum.
Çünkü
ikinci
constructor
bizden
o rast
kere
sayı
aralığını
istiyor.
Mesela
Şimdi
aslında
bu
neyi
yazmanın
kısa yolu?
Şöyle
yazmanın
kısa yolu.
Constructor'a
gönderdiğim
argümanların
intürden
olduğunu görünce
derleyici
stat
dediğimiz
özellikle
class
template
argument
deduction
ama
C++
ve sonrası
ne yapıyor
arkadaşlar?
Compile
time'da
template
argümanının
int olması
gerektiğini
anlıyor.
Eğer
örneğin
şöyle
olsaydı
bu durumda
all
signed
int
olacaktı.
Böyle
olsaydı
syntax
hatası
olacaktı.
çünkü
değerler
birbirinden
farklı
template
argument
deduction
yapılamayacaktı.
Edway'e
örnek
verelim
şimdi
Burada
dikkat etmemiz
gereken bir noktada
o aralıktaki
ikinci
değerin
yani
değerinin
onun da
üretilecek
olması.
Şimdi
kez
dönen
döngü
içinde
ben
DIST'in
fonksiyon çağrı
operatör fonksiyonuna
enge
argüman
olarak
gönderiyorum.
Ve
üretilen
rastgele
sayıları
yazdırıyorum.
Daha doğrusu
üretilip
dağıtılan
böyle demek
daha doğru.
Aralığı
biraz
azaltalım
olsun.
Tabi
istediğim
aralığı
seçebilirim.
Bakın
Şimdi
ben size
asıl önemli olan
konu göstereceğim.
Arkadaşlar
bu matematiksel olarak
işte
Uniform Distribution
bakın bunu
kanıtlayacağım.
Şimdi şöyle bir şey
yapalım.
İzleyin.
Uniform
Distribution'la
arkadaşlar
Uniform
Distribution
sınıfını
kullanın.
Hocam
Dist
Enk'te
üretilen
değerleri
aralığına
mı
sıkıştırıyor?
Evet
Alihan
tamamen
bunu yapıyor
ama
bunu
Uniform
olarak
yapıyor.
Uniform
olarak
yapması
ne demek?
Şimdi
onu göstereceğim
işte.
Yani
34'ün
35'in
36'nın
37'nin
38'in
39'un
üretilme
olasılığı
aynı
eşit.
ona
Uniform
Distribution
deniyor.
Şimdi bunu
gösterelim.
Bakın
son derece
basit.
Ne yapacağım
tahmin edebiliyor
musunuz?
Diyelim ki
1 milyon tane
rastgele sayı
üreteceğim.
Onların
hangi değerden
kaç tane
üretildiğini
sayacağım.
Onu da
standart
altta
yazdıracağım.
Birbirine yakın
değerler olduğunu
göreceksiniz.
izleyin.
Bu sefer
zar değeri
olsun diye
aralığını
seçiyorum.
Parz
edin ki
bu
tavla
zarı
üretilecek
değer.
Map
başlık
dosyasını
inklud
ediyorum.
Arkadaşlar
hatırlıyorsunuz
idiomatik
kodumuzu
değil mi?
Ve
şimdi
diyelim ki
1 milyon
kez dönen
döngüde
BIST
ENG
bir tane
MAP nesnesi
oluşturuyorum.
MAP'in
INT virgül
arkadaşlar
INT açılımı
C MAP
değerleri
sayma
amaçlı
kullanacağım.
İdiomatik
yapıyı
hatırlıyoruz
değil mi?
C MAP
köşeli
parantez
operatör
fonksiyonu
artı
18.
satırda
yazdığım
for döngüsüyle
implement edilen
idiomu
MAP sınıfına
anlatırken
anlatmıştım
onu tekrar
etmeyeceğim.
Ama
şimdi bakın
MAP'i
dolaşıyorum
for
auto
dice
count
c
out
dice
boşluk
pound
newline
koda bir bakın
ne yaptığını
ben kodu anlamadım
diyen varsa
tekrar edeyim
arkadaşlar
aslında
uniform
it distribution
nesnesini
kullanarak
MT19937'nin
ürettiği
rastgele
sayıları
input olarak
alıp
1-6
aralığında
uniform
olarak
dağıtıyorum
bu durumda
üretim
sayısı
arttıkça
1-6
yakınlaması
gerekiyor
olasılık
bu demek
zaten
bakınız
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
tesadüf
değil bu
167.104
166.774
birbirine
yakın
değerler
şimdi
burada
1 milyon
değil
örneğin
1 milyar
olsaydı
1 bölü
6'ya
daha fazla
yakınlayacaktı
biraz zaman
alacak
bu durumda
evet
1 milyar
biraz fazla oldu
sanırım
1 milyar
olmasın
da
10 milyon
olsun
evet
görüyorsunuz
1 milyon
663.852
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
1 milyon
660'a
kadar
aynı
yani ne
kadar
birbirine
yakın
değerler
üniform
indistribü
şunun
ne olduğunu
anladık
değil mi
işte
mesela
bizim o
kar örneğimizde
eğer burada
duruyorsa
izleyin
bakın
buradaki kodda da
onu kullandım
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
MT19937
ENG
nesnenin
statik olması
çok çok önemli
statik yerel nesne
olması
çünkü eğer
statik yerel nesne
olmazsa
create random
kar fonksiyonunu
her çağırdığımızda
MT19937
tekrar
konstrakt olacak
onun
konstrakt edilmesinin
ciddi bir
maliyeti
var
altta da
uniform
indistribü
sınıfı
türünden
nesne
tanımladığımı
görüyorsunuz
burada
7 tane
farklı araba
olduğu için
8 tane
farklı araba
olduğu için
aralığında
rastgele
sayı ürettim
ve
bunları
switch'te
case'ler
case label'larının
sabitleri
olarak kullandım
böylece
aslında
burada
neyi sağlamış
oluyoruz
bunların
her birinin
gelme
olasılığı
birbiriyle
aynı
oluyor
değil mi
uniform
dağılım
bu demek
ama
mesela
gerçek sayı
dağılımına
bakalım
şimdi de
şuraya kadar
aynı olsun
arkadaşlar
fakat
uniform
indistribüüsününün yerini
real
distribution
alalım
burada da
aralık
gerçek sayı
argümanları
istiyor
mesela
boy örneğine
bakalım
arkadaşlar
izleyin
efendim
nokta
yani
ve
türünü de
double yapalım
ikinci
aralığın sonu da
ne olsun
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
tabi
bunda da
bulunması lazım
deduction yapılabilmesi için
ve şimdi
arkadaşlar
bu sefer şöyle
görsel
takip edebilmeniz için
şöyle bir şey yapalım
see out
fixed
set precision
bunları hatırlıyorsunuz
değil mi
iomanic başlık dosyasını da
ekleyelim
fixed
set precision
efendim
yani
fixed moda aldım
noktalı olarak
yazacak
ama
noktadan sonra
2 basamak
yazacak
yine
app
stream
başlık dosyasını
alıyorum
şuradaki dosyalardan
biri yine açalım
out
nokta
txt
arkadaşlar
evet
out nokta
txt
şimdi
diyelim ki
20 bin tane
gerçek sayı
yazalım
i eşittir
sıfır
i küçük
hatta
50 bin olsun
yine
see out
dist
ng
şimdi artık
o sürekli
aralıkta
gerçek sayılar
olduğu için
50 bin tane
1.45
1.95
arasında
belki test
değeri olarak
kullanılacak
değer oluşturacağım
ama tabi bu
sadece
uniform real distribution
sınıfını
göstermek için
yoksa
burada
normal dağılım
olmalı
yani gerçek
hayatı modellemek
istiyorsak
kesinlikle ve kesinlikle
burada
uniform dağılım
değil
birazdan
öğrenmeye
başlayacağımız
ya da göstermeye
gauss
dağılımı
kullanılmalıydı
o standart
altında
yazmışız
tabi çok
yavaş oluyor
o zaman
şimdi
dosyaya
yazıyorum
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
dosyadaki
değerleri
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
gerçek test
adası
gibi
evet
185.687
177.34
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
evet
şimdi
geliyorum
normal dağılım
arkadaşlar bu arada
çok önemli
bir iki tane
not
az önce
en az
4-5 kere
farklı
derleyicilerin
aynı
enjin türünü
kullanarak
aynı tohum
değeriyle
sayı
öğretmeniz
durumunda
derleyicilerde
fark olmadığını
söyledim hatta
gösterdim
GCC derleyicisiyle
benim kullandığım
Microsoft
derleyicisi
her ikisi de
aynı
değeri
üretti
fakat
dağılım sınıfları
için böyle bir
özellik yok
yani
örneğin
bir önceki
kodda
uniform
int distribution
kodunda
ben
aralığı
aynı
alsam
dohum değerini
aynı
alsam
dahi
aynı sayılar
elde etme
garantisi
yok
yani
dağılım sınıfları
ne
değil
arkadaşlar
aynı
şekilde
implemente
edilmek
zorunda
değil
ona güvenerek
kod yazmayın
fakat
dağılım sınıflarının da
her
dağılım sınıfının
kendine özgü
değerleri var
mesela
uniform
int distribution
ve uniform
real distribution
da şüphesiz
buradaki
kritik değerler
aralığın
başlangıcı
ve sonu
ama
Gauss
dağılımında
yani
normal
dağılımda
hepinizin
bildiği gibi
bize bir
mean
yani
ortalama
bir de
standart
deviation
lazım
yani
onun
parametreleri
farklı
şimdi
o yüzden
burası
biraz karmaşık
gelecek
sınıfın
interfersinde
bu değerleri
get etmeye
yönelik
fonksiyonlar
var
yani
örneğin
bakın
distin
arkadaşlar
A ve B
değerleri
aslında
aralığın
başlangıcı
ve aralığın
sonu
max ve min
değerleri
üretilebilecek
en büyük ve en küçük
sayılar
ama
A ve B
aralığın
başlangıcı
ve sonu
fakat
bir özelliği
daha var
bakın
burası
ilginç
şimdi
özellikle
bundan sonraki
sınıflar
daha karmaşık
olduğu için
bu
önem taşıyor
sınıfın
param isimli
bir fonksiyonu
var
arkadaşlar
param
tahmin ediyorsunuz
değil mi
neden kısaltma
parameters
parametrelerden
kısaltma
bu
her
dağılım
sınıfının
aslında
param type
isimli
bir nested type'ı
var
ve siz
param
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınızda
arkadaşlar
o
param type
türünden
size bir değer
döndürerek
parametreleri
get etmenizi
sağlıyor
iyi necati
onları get edip
ne yapacağım
anlatacağım
yine
constructora
bu
param
fonksiyonundan
aldığınız
değeri
geçerseniz
ya da
yine
bir başka nesnenin
param
fonksiyonuna
bu seferde
set
overloadunu
geçerseniz
o parametreleri
kazandırmış
oluyorsunuz
yani bu
mesela
burada sadece
iki tane
parametre var
ama bazı
dağıtım sınıfları
var ki
7-8 tane
parametreye
sahip
yani o
dağılımı
etkileyen
ihtiyaç duyulan
7-8 tane
ayrı değer var
o zaman
onları
tek tek
kullanmak
yerine
param
fonksiyonunu
çağırıp
parametreleri
get edebiliyorsunuz
peki
şimdi
gelelim
normal
dağılıma
bakın
normal
dağılım
hoşunuza
gidecek
normal
dağılımda
bize bir
ortalama
değeri
gerekiyor
ve bir de
arkadaşlar
standart
sapma
değeri
gerekiyor
standart
sapma
ne kadar
küçükse
o
çan eğrisi
o kadar
küçük
olacak
değil mi
mean
değeri
aslında
çan eğrisindeki
peak değeri
olacak
ama
işte
ortalamadan
uzaklaştıkça
standart
sapma
ölçüsünde
olasılık
azalacak
ama şimdi
ben bunu
size gayet
güzel göstereceğim
bakınız
yine
mt19.9.37
nesnem
kalsın
bu sefer
normal
distribution
sınıfı
türünden
yine
bunun da
template
argümanı
gerçek sayı
türü
ve default
template
argümanı
arkadaşlar
double
ama siz
isterseniz
float'u
ya da
long double'ı
seçebilirsiniz
gerçek sayı
türü
olmalı
ya da
yine
constructor'a
geçinen
argümanların
türünden
parametre
template
parametrelerine
karşılık
gelen
argümanların
çıkarımının
yapılmasını
sağlayabilirsiniz
ama şimdi
bakın
sizden iki tane
değer istiyor
izleyin
bir tanesi
birinci parametre
ortalama
ikinci parametre
standart
sapma
mesela ortalamayı
belli
alalım
standart
sapmayı
bir
alalım
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
ve distribution
nesnemizi
bu şekilde
oluşturalım
ve
ilk
görsel olarak
seçmeniz
biraz zor olacak
ama çok daha
güzelini yapacağım
ve yüz tane
rastgele
gerçek sayıyı
üretelim
gauss
alımına göre
belki görsel olarak
seçmeniz zor olacak
ama birazdan bir
grafik şeklinde
göstereceğim
o zaman
kolay
algılayacaksınız
see out
this
enge
çalıştırıyorum
evet bakın
gerçekten de
50 civarında
yoğunlaştığını
görüyorsunuz
ama standart
sapma
bir olduğu için
arkadaşlar
değerlerin
yüzde
hatırlayın
99'u
o bir
standart
sapma içinde
kalıyor
ama şimdi
daha güzel bir şey
yapacağız
bakın bakın
ne yapacağız
yine bir dosya
oluşturalım
bu sefer
100 bin tane
sayı üreteceğim
dikkat edin
fakat
100 bin tane
sayı üretip
bunun bir
grafiğini
çizdireceğim
necat nasıl
grafiği
çizdireceksin
son derece
basit
arkadaşlar
yine bir
map
oluşturacağım
mapin
int virgül
int açılımı
simep
üretilen sayı
şu ya
pist
enge
izleyin
bunu
int türüne
kest edeceğim
arkadaşlar
hatta
round yapayım
ve
static
kest
int
int türüne
kest
edeyim
ve
map'e
ekleyeyim
simep
köşeli
parantez
artı
yazdığım kodu
anladınız mı
evet
şimdi ne yapacağım
tahmin edin
bunun
grafiğini
çizdireceğim
necat
nasıl çizdireceksin
ya son derece
basit
şimdi
şu değer
işte
gibi
değer olacak
ve bu da
onun sayısı
dolayısıyla
bu sayının
belirli bir
faktöre bölünmesiyle
elde edilecek
yıldız
bastırıyor
onu yapmak da
çok kolay
bakın
for
yine
const
ya da
çok fazla
kopyalama
maliyeti yok
auto
structure
binding
kullanıyorum
height
count
cmap
arkadaşlar
önce
height'ı
yazdırsın
ama
tabi ki
count'ı
yazdırmayacağım
şöyle yapacağım
bir boşluk
vereyim
ve
string başlık
dosyasını
dahil ediyorum
arkadaşlar
string'in
size t
constructor'ı
vardı ya
string
mesela
10 tane
hatırlayacak
mısınız
a karakteri
bu
constructor'ı
herkes
hatırlıyor
mu
o zaman
burada
birinci
parametreyi
Alihan
100 bin
göz kararı
count
bölü
diyelim
ikinci parametreye de
yıldız
geçelim
ve sonra da
new line
verelim
evet
bakın şimdi
yıldız sayısını
belki
biraz daha
ince
ayar
yapabiliriz
çok fazla
olmuş
şöyle
100 yapalım
%
fazla olur
evet
% biraz fazla
oldu
siyah
dosyaya
yazdıracaktım
ops
dosyayı
oluşturduk mu
evet
çünkü
standart
altlıkta
iyi
görünmüyor
evet
şimdi bakın
dosyaya
100 de
çok büyük
geldi
500 yapalım
evet
bakın
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
standart satma
ortalama
pik noktası
ama
ortalamadan
uzaklaştıkça
azalıyor
gördünüz
değil mi
evet
şimdi standart
satmayı
arttıracağım
standart
satma
1'di
şurada set
etmiştim
standart
satmayı
arkadaşlar
bakalım
tabi
tam sayı
olması
gerekmiyor
şimdi
dağılıma
bakalım
biraz daha
yayıldığını
göreceksiniz
efendim
yapalım
biraz daha
yayılacak
ama yine
pik noktası
görüyorsunuz
bu sefer
arkadaşlar
5 yapalım
şurada da
yıldız sayısını
250 yapalım
böyle 250
5 standart satma
bakın
ne güzel bir çanı gerisi oluştu
değil mi
50 merkezde
pik noktası
ve
50'den
uzaklaştık
tabi çanı gerisinin
önemli özelliği
yine simetrik
olması
normal dağılımın
yani
50'den
büyük olanlarla
küçük olan taraf
tamamen
birbiriyle
simetrik
görüyorsunuz
normal dağılım
anlaşıldı
değil mi
arkadaşlar
şimdi
işte bakın
az önceki örnekte
boyları
normal dağılımla
üretseydim
diyelim ki
ortalamayı
170 alsaydım
ya da
160 alsaydım
160 boyu
160 olan
o mean değeri
pik noktası
olacaktı
1.70
1.80
1.90
standart satmanın
ne olduğuna
bağlı olarak
yayılacaktı
yine
normal distribution
sınıfının da
bakın
bist
nokta
yine
max ve
mean fonksiyonları
var
ama bu kez
ABB
değerleri
değil
mean
ve sigma
değerleri
var
yani
mean
aritmetik
ortalama
sigma
da
standart
satma
ama
hepsini
beraber
almak
istiyorsanız
yine
görüyorsunuz
sınıfın
nested
type
olan
param
type
türünden
değer
döndüren
hem
set
hem de
get
fonksiyonu
var
parametreleri
almanız
için
şimdi
gelelim
arkadaşlar
Bernoulli
dağılımına
dağılımı
çok basit
bakın
bir kere
Bernoulli
dağılımı
template
değil
yani
Bernoulli
dağılımı
gerçek sınıf
bir sınıf
şablonu
değil
bizden
sadece
arkadaşlar
ne istiyor
true
ve false
olarak
olasılık
değerini
istiyor
mesela
diyelim ki
0.50
aldım
şimdi
üretilen
sayıların
yarısı
arkadaşlar
true olacak
yarısı
false olacak
isterseniz
bunu
yine
şöyle
ölçelim
tam
0.5'e
yakın
sadığını
1 milyon
tane
sayı
oluşturdum
üretiyorum
dist
eng
yine
arkadaşlar
bu sefer
tabi sadece
iki değer olduğu için
map kullanmama
gerek yok
int
count
arkadaşlar
efendim
true döndürürse
artı artı
count
eğer tamamen
0.5
olsaydı
bunun
neye yakın
saması
gerekirdi
1 milyar
olduğuna göre
1 milyon
bine yakın
saması
gerekirdi
see
out
count
görüyorsunuz
bakın
ne kadar
yakın
efendim
1 milyon
değil
1 milyar
yapalım
biraz daha
uzun sür
çek
burada da
yine
bakın
milyon
bin
ama tabi
buradaki
konstruktora
geçtiğim argüman
0.5
olmak zorunda
değil
mesela
0.25
olsaydı
o zaman
1 bölü
4 oranıyla
true olacak
3 bölü
4 oranıyla
false
olacak
yani bu kodda da
ne yazmasını
bekliyoruz
1 milyar
olduğuna göre
milyon
10'a yakın
bir değer
bulması lazım
yani
verili bir
olasılıkla
2 değerden
birini
seçmeniz
gerekiyorsa
arkadaşlar
o zaman
Bernoulli
dağılımı
ideal
evet
görüyorsunuz
milyon
bin
anlaşıldı mı
Bernoulli
dağılımının
ne yaptığı
evet
şimdi de
discreet
dağılımı
görelim
arkadaşlar
bu özellikle
oyun programlarında
falan çok işe yarıyor
çünkü
bu
discreet
distribution
sınıfını
kullanarak
siz
istediğiniz değere
istediğiniz
olasılığı
verebiliyorsunuz
mesela
şimdi şöyle bir
uygulama yapalım
bir
hileli
zar
tabi burada
hileli
zar derken
bu matematiksel
bir terim
burada
biz hileli
diyoruz ama
İngilizce'de
kullanılan terim
biliyorsunuz
değil mi
biased
diyorlar
hileli
bir
zar
mesela
gelme
olasılığı
biraz daha
yüksek
olsun
yani
oyunda
biz
1 2 3 4 5'in
gelme
olasılıkları
birbirine yakın
ama altının olasılığını
biraz daha
yükselteceğiz
şimdi nasıl
yapıyorum
bakın burası
biraz
karmaşık
bir kere
sınıfımın ismi
discrete distribution
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
yine bir
template parametresi
var
template parametresinde
argüman
default
int
argüman
yani
intörden
değerler
söz konusu
ve
list
izleyin
arkadaşlar
şimdi burada
constructora
her geçtiğiniz sayı
her bir değeri
sıfırdan başlayarak
olasılıklarını gösterecek
mesela
sıfır için
sıfır
bir için
arkadaşlar
yirmi
iki için
üç için
yirmi
dört için
beş için
yirmi
altı için
yirmi iki
şimdi bu ne demek
arkadaki
kod
bunların
ağır
ortalamasına
olacak
yani
toplumunu
yüze
tamamlamak
zorunda
falan
kesinlikle
değilsiniz
bu arada
constructora
argüman
olarak
bu örnekte
olduğu gibi
initializer list
constructora
değerleri
geçebilirsiniz
ya da
bunu
bir
konteynerda
tutup
range
constructorı
kullanabilirsiniz
yani
konteynerdaki
öğeleri
öğeler
bu durumda
bu olasılık
değerleri
olacak
tabi bunlar
gerçek sayı
olabilir
yani bu
parametre
zaten
double türden
takip edebiliyor muyuz
şimdi bakın
gerçekten
böyle mi
yine
map'in
int virgül
int açılımı
cmap
arkadaşlar
1 milyon sayı
üretelim
yine
ist
enge
map'e
insert
edelim
cmap
ve art
art
operatörün
operandı
yapalım
şimdi yine
range
base
for loop
kullanıp
structure
binding'e
auto
dice
count
cmap
see out
dice
count
evet
arkadaşlar
net
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
bakın
şimdi
izleyin
şunu
yapmışım
yanlışlıkla
yapıyorum
bakın
şimdi
bu ne
demek
1'in
gelme
olasılığı
bölü
evet
Alihan ben de
sonra gördüm
teşekkür ederim
2'nin gelme
olasılığı
arkadaşlar
bölü
ama
6'nın gelme
olasılığı
biraz daha fazla
bakalım
bu değerler
seçici
gözümüz seçebilecek mi
6'nın fazla olduğunu
evet
bakın
bu kadar
fark bile
bunu
bin
yaptı
yani
öyle bir
hile zarı
oluşturabiliriz ki
insan
fark etmeyebilir
sürekli
zar hattında
yapalım
biraz daha
an bayis
dolmaya
yakın
olsun
arkadaşlar
evet
bakın
164 bin
165 bin
ama
174 bin
tane
anlaşıldı
değil mi
burada
bu değerleri
bir konteynerde
da tutabiliriz
örneğin
vektörün
double açılımı
devek
bunlar
bunlar ayları
temsil etsin
yani her bir değer
bir ay olsun
arkadaşlar
ocak
şubat
mart
nisan
mayıs
12 aydan
biri
ve
şöyle yapalım
vektörü dolaşalım
devek
i
eşittir
arkadaşlar
1 bölü
takip edebiliyor muyuz
ama
şu anda hepsinin olasılığı
aynı
ama bir tanesini
değiştirelim
mesela
hangi ay
haziran ayı
değil mi
ya da aralık
daha kolay olsun
devek
bek
artı eşit
0 nokta
arkadaşlar
yine map'in
int virgül
int açılımı
sime
bu sefer
10 milyon
tane
ve yazdırıyorum
dolayısıyla
ekrana yazılan
ilk sayı
arkadaşlar
ocak
için olacak
sonra şubat
için
ama
aralık
şu
şurayı
değiştirmemişim
evet şimdi
discrete distribution
nesnesinin
konstruktörüne
bu vektörün
rengini
argüman olarak
geçeceğim
yani
devek
begin
end
evet süper oldu
aralık en sonuncu
olasılığı
daha fazla
evet bakın
arkadaşlar
aralığında
bir dakika
bir yerde
bir yanlışlık
yaptık
devek
begin
end
1 bölü
10 yapmışım
yani
iyi küçük
tabii böyle yazarsam
hataya da
hvetiye çıkartıyorum
devek
size
ben de diyorum
ne oluyor
size t
iyi
tamam
şimdi oldu
sanırım
1 bölü
evet
arkadaşlar görüyorsunuz
hepsi 79
milyon
bu olmuş
1 milyon
çok fazla arttırmışız
olasılığı
biraz daha
az olsun
hatta yazdırırken de
dice
değil artık bu
şurayı da düzeltelim
month
hatta
şöyle yapalım
daha önceki konularımızda da bir örnek olsun
const char
bir önceki kodda vardı aslında ama onu saklamadık sanırım
şu ay örneğinde
bir dakikanızı rica edip hemen onu bulayım ben
şu ayları oluşturan
ha date de vardı sanırım
hemen date cpp'yi bulalım
evet
şuradaki diziyi alalım
şuraya yapıştıralım
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet bakın
sıfır indeksi
ocak olacak bu durumda
ve
month'ı
yazdırmıyorum
imus dizisinin
month isim
indisli
arkadaşlar
öyesi olan yazıyı yazdırıyorum
ne güzel oldu değil mi
böylece
aralığa kadar
ayların
kaç tane geldiğini
ocaktan şubattan
görebileceğiz
evet
formatta yazmadık
şöyle yapalım o zaman
bir de set v manipülatörünü
kullanalım
set v
tabi left manipülatörünü de
kullanmamız gerekiyor
see out
left
şimdi artık
nihai haline
getirdik
evet
arkadaşlar görüyorsunuz
bakın ocak şubat
aralık
daha fazla
görüyorsunuz değil mi
hatta istersem
şöyle bile
yazabilirim
1 bölü 12
debek
köşeli parantezi
artı eşit
arkadaşlar
i çarpı
0.05
0.03
böylece ne olacak
ay büyüdükçe
olasılığı da artacak
yani
yılın sonu
belki de böyle bir model
gerekiyor
diyelim ki bir
test datası için
ay arttıkça
olasılığının da
artması gerekiyor
yani
yılın ilk
aylarında
az satış var
mesela
ay ilerledikçe
yılın sonuna doğru
geldikçe
daha fazla
satış oluyor
gibi
aa şu
deki kaldırmam
gerekiyor
yalnız
şurayı
düzeltelim
yanlış olmadı
değil mi
mantık
evet
şunu da
tek bir
deyim yapalım
yok
pardon
şunu sileceğim
evet
1 bölü 12
artı
sanıyorum
bir yanlışlık yok
aylara göre
yağmur yağma
olasılığı
diyor
Alihan
olabilir
bakın ne güzel oldu
değil mi
Ocak 279
Şubat
giderek
artıyor
istediğimiz gibi
ayarlayabiliyoruz
arkadaşlar son olarak
standart kütüphanede
daha önce de
görmüştük ama
o zaman
daha bu
rastgele sayı
üretici
sınıfları
işlememiştik
algoritmalardan
bazı algoritmalarda
bu sınıf
nesnelerinin
kullanımına da
bir bakalım
algoritm
başlık dosyasında
örnek
şunlar kalsın
vektörün
int açılımı
ibek
izleyin
generate
şimdi birkaç tane örnek
bakın generate
bizden bir
generator istiyor
değil mi
az önce
birinci derste
bu kodu
yazmıştım
efendim
100 bin tane
öv olsun
şimdi diyelim ki
burayı
belirli aralıkta
rastgele sayılarla
doldurmamız
gerekiyor olsun
generate
ibek begin
ibek end
buraya dikkat
daha önce bu örneği
hatırlıyorsunuz
değil mi
call by value
değil de
call by reference
olarak geçmek için
ne yapabilirim
lambda ifadesi de
kullanmama gerek yok
reference
wrapper
sınıfını
kullanabilirim
değil mi
ref
en
mg
hatta
bu durumda
sayılar hangi
aralıkta
olacak
doğrudan
benim rastgele sayı
üreticim
kullanıldığı için
arkadaşlar
int max
aralığında
olacak
ama şöyle
yazarsam
yine
uniform
int distribution
list
bu da
örneğin
aralığında
olsun
ya da
aralığında
olsun
rastgele
sayılarımız
bu sefer
lambda
ifadesi
oluşturalım
ve
listi ve
enge
referans yoluyla
capture
edelim
burada
capture
all by ref
de diyebilirdim
zaten
kullandıklarımı
alacak
sınıfa
veri elemanı
olarak
ama referans
semantiğiyle
alacak
fonksiyonun
parametresi
yok
return
list
nng
böylece
vektörü
aralığında
rastgele
sayılarla
doldurdum
arkadaşlar
bir başka örnek
shuffle
bakın
yine elimde
bir vektör var
hatta
şöyle güzel
bir kod
yazalım
bakın
şimdi
başta
string
sınıfını
kullanalım
string
vale
olsun
bu
stringdeki karakterler
iskambik kağıdı
destesindeki
facelere
tutuyor
olsun
ben
Türkçe okuyorum
Fransızçadan gelen
isimler
şimdi
shuffle
algoritmasına
bakın
shuffle
arkadaşlar
bu sefer
shuffle
algoritmasında
üçüncü parametre
universal
referans
yani
l value
ve r value
olarak gönderebiliyorum
o yüzden
az önceki kodu
tekrar yazalım
mp19
en
g
random
device
ve
bakın
shuffle
sbgin
sant
ve
efendim
eng
şimdi bunu
rastgele ne yapacak
kağıtları
dağıtacak
izleyin
hatta bunu
şöyle
10 kez
dönen bir döngüde
yapalım
ve ondan sonra
yazdıralım
siyahat
arkadaşlar
s
bazen böyle
random device
parantezlerinin yeri
yanlış olmuş
diyor
arkadaşım
evet
doğru söylüyorsunuz
bu geçi nesne
oluşturma
sentaksı
şurayı da
düzelteyim
evet
random device
türünde
bakın şöyle de
olur aslında
çünkü geçi nesneyi
küme paranteziyle
oluşturmak zorunda
değilim
böyle de olur
Alihan
değil mi
ya da
ikinci tabi
parantez olmak
zorunda
ama bu küme
parantezde
olabilir
şimdi oldu
şuraya da bir
getkar çağrısı
koyalım
void
getkar
evet
burada da
bizim rastgele
sayı üreticisini
kullanarak
rastgele
dağıtıyor
işte bakın
bunların kağıt
olduğunu düşün
4,7,3,8,2
ruha
asfale
5,6
10'lu
9'lu
ve dam
her tuşa
bastığımda
farklı bir şekilde
İslamül kağıdını
dağıttığımı
düşündüğüm
her renkte
evet
bugünkü ve bu
haftaki derslerimiz de
burada sona
yarıyor
bir dahaki
pazartesi günü
görüşmek üzere
herkese
iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar
şamlar
el listings
18 cross
excuse
teşekkür ederim
abone ol
videoyu